No sound is their song.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I should've known.
I couldn't hear myself.
Well,
it's recorded on here.
So the replays,
the replays,
what happened?
But nobody wants to watch the replays.
Goddammit.
Let's recap what I talked.
Hilarious clusterfuck,
haircut,
pause.
We're gonna.
Need that one might be in the audio
because you hear them well.
Let's recap what we're talking about.
Well,
we're upset here.
I said some genius shit.
Probably the most profound shit I've
ever seen in my life.
Anyway.
What I said in the beginning,
the very beginning was that,
um,
I'm excited to do these,
uh,
ustream broadcast and I'm excited that I
decided to do it because I liked doing
radio interviews and I'm like doing tv
interviews and that's all fun magazine
stuff was fun,
but it's way cooler to just be able to
talk to people and answer people's
questions directly,
you know,
and it's,
it's easy to get a weird impression of
someone,
you know,
seeing someone on television.
The television represent too,
to a certain extent.
You know,
it's like a lot of these guys in the
reality shows to get upset like
television doesn't,
you know,
it represents you in little snippets and
cuts you up,
you know,
but the best way to communicate with
people for sure is the Internet and
twitter and Ustream.
So combining the two of them together,
what we're doing is,
um,
we're gonna I'm going to do this every
week.
The thing behind me,
all this bullshit behind me that's all
going to get cleared out and we're gonna
put up a green screen so we could have
like space behind us and shit and we're
going to have this thing set up at a
little bit more natural angle.
So you'll be looking right at us,
which makes more sense,
right?
Yeah.
You can put it anywhere you want.
You can put it right there.
Is that right?
In the middle?
Yeah.
Move this motherfucker.
But there's the.
I got,
I upgraded my internet,
I had some old ass dsl.
It was pretty whack and I got rid of it.
Uh,
today actually,
totally had got it set up.
Is this Scorp now?
Much better.
Um,
so,
um,
the,
uh,
the DSL is gone and now I got cable and
cables,
fastest flux,
so we're going to be able to air videos
and shit while it's going on.
And um,
my,
my mom designed my office purple shades
browse around purple.
It's a beautiful color.
You don't like that color
should be fucking black dude with
skulls.
Like your fucking shirt,
bro.
There's nothing wrong with purple,
my friend.
It's a beautiful color.
And there's Brian's he,
Brian in the corner there.
Brian is actually right next to me,
but he's getting facebook by that
advertisement.
You're going to get facebook.
You should move yourself up.
Can you move yourself up right next to
go?
That's better because you're not going
to it
fucked by that.
Uh,
no.
Don't go all the way up there right
there.
No right number.
Let's move over towards my head.
Go this way,
right?
No,
that's cool.
That's Brian.
Brian's right next door to me
anyway,
we're just talking about the Internet
being an awesome.
It's the fucking coolest thing ever.
I mean,
to be able to communicate with people
directly like this,
to be able to get the answers to any
question at any time.
To me it's the greatest fucking thing in
the world.
I spent most of my day staring at a
screen reading stories,
watching fucking youtube videos and
have,
I swear I've learned more from the
Internet more from just being on message
boards than I ever have from,
you know,
from other shit.
I've gotten into all sorts of different
subjects because of message boards,
you know,
and,
and wound up being fans of musicians and
comedians and people I would have never
heard of.
It wasn't from message boards.
It's like a whole online part.
I meet more people online than I do in
real life now and I don't just live in
my house.
I go out a lot more people interested in
the same things.
I like to get to know him better on the
Internet.
Yeah,
well the Internet allows you when
someone posts for a long time,
especially a message board community,
you get to see how they interact with
other people.
You get to see what happens when you
know they're.
They're challenged on their ideas.
You get to see.
You get to see what they're made of.
You know?
It's really interesting.
Yeah.
You would.
The way people write is different than
the way they talk because people can
think they're slick and they could try
to bullshit.
You buy really patiently scribing out.
They're words,
but they're not tricking you.
Eventually eventually that shit just
comes out because they don't realize how
douchey they are.
They don't realize they think they're
not Douchey,
but in your writing,
the Douchey always comes out.
It's like,
this is your.
It's your expression is almost like a
printout of you.
It's like,
it's like,
you know,
like your dna or something like that.
You know what I mean?
Google helps too because then you catch
a lot of people.
It's the best.
It's the best catch clinical.
What are you talking about?
Check out these photos.
Love to talk shit.
People love to pretend that they know
things.
Nobody wants to pretend that they're
fucking clueless.
You know,
everybody wants to be the wizard.
Everybody wants to be the smartest man
in the world,
you know,
nobody could just be a person.
You know.
It's real interesting,
man.
It's real,
it's real interesting.
But people love to talk shit and for the
longest time they just got away with it
for the longest time.
People can bullshit.
I'm going to text message someone says
is just coming in from Shandra,
are you with Joe?
So any chance of doing a Miami
interview,
tell that bitch we're doing a podcast.
She should know three to five is
podcast.
I said bitch with the highest level of
affection.
So I'll just in fun ladies gentlemen.
So,
um,
what do we got here?
She checked it out.
Any of the photos or videos of that
hurricane damage.
Have you been here?
The earthquake in Haiti.
Earthquake?
Yeah.
I'm sorry,
I haven't seen that man heard the CNN
thing that I got on my phone.
I get breaking important news stories on
my phone.
The last one I got before this one was
that Simon callow's quitting American
idol.
Motherfuck awful too though.
Is it awful movie?
If you watch American idol without,
that's the only point,
a reason to watch it is past people that
things that he says.
I really.
Yeah,
right now.
So he was Ryan seacrest.
Beautiful Hair.
Wasn't saying some brutal dude.
He's genius.
He's a genius.
He's hilarious.
He's one of the best.
Really.
Okay.
I need to wash it off and I don't have a
good opinion of him.
My and my opinion of ms dot has always
mean to these people that are trying
hard to like,
they suck,
you know,
like you can't.
I mean,
I,
I guess he can be mean,
but you know,
why do it?
They're all fucked in the head,
you know?
I mean,
I think it's kind of funny,
but that guy puts out a lot of negative
energy.
Well,
he's blatantly honest.
He's like,
he is,
he's not really neat.
He's just so honest that it's me.
You know what I mean?
Like he's really interesting when he
says,
because like he'll say he's dead rotted
percent of the time.
I've only watched it like literally
twice and one that I can remember when I
was so hot.
I don't even know what happened,
but one I can remember and it was just
painfully clueless.
People who are just trying to be like
the shit,
you know,
and they'd get out there and they don't
even know that they have no talent
whatsoever,
but I know so many people like that from
standup comedy,
you know,
we all know dudes from stand up comedy
who never feel like they're bombing.
They,
you know,
in the beginning you'd have done open
Mike Nights.
You know what it's like.
There's,
there's some people in an open mic
night,
communities that are crazy and they
really think they're good and they would
love to have an opportunity to do
something like American idol for
standup.
They would get up there and go fucking
crazy and be upset and just like those
American people are,
they get fucking mad.
I've seen some people,
they,
they leave that Simon cowel dude and
start fucking crying and wailing and
yelling at him.
You don't know Shit Simon,
you know,
they get fucking angry man.
Black women especially.
Right?
I don't even know if black women,
especially C to fucking episode.
No,
I'm talking about.
Let's talk about black girls get mad
though because I'm not a huge fan or
anything,
but every time I see an episode I'm just
bawling.
How hilarious.
Wow.
So he's gonna do his own show called the
x factor.
He's basically dual supposedly and so
he's pretty much going to leave or why
not have Paula Abdul.
Are they stupid?
They're like,
she's incompetent.
Yeah,
that's part of the fun man.
You need to pill that bitch up and just
proper up.
Just shove a broom up,
harass and push her forward and get her
in front of the camera.
Let her talk crazy.
That's part of the fun of the show,
right,
isn't it?
Yeah,
I think so.
I don't.
I had the little clips that I would get,
like people send me one of them
occasionally,
like the one where she said your first
song,
it was really cool,
but your second side and like.
And they were like,
he only just sang one song,
like she's so fucking blacked out of it.
You know why she was in a car accident
real supposedly,
but it's like real pain.
Oh,
well,
you know what happens,
man,
you,
that's what happened.
Breezy and tube.
No car preseason.
Um,
got a,
a real bad injury and took pain pills.
They're,
yeah,
they're the pain pills or a motherfucker
man.
I know a lot of people that have had
problems with pain pills,
you know,
people with anything sort of a chronic
problem.
Well you have to take them,
you know,
those motherfuckers there grab a hold of
you and it's not just,
you know,
the week or you know,
people like that.
People have a weird opinion of people
that get hooked on drugs,
you know.
But I've met some Carl prisons,
you know,
I dunno,
I dunno if I'm just saying I shouldn't
say Carl because I don't think Carl has
a problem with them.
I think Carlos and some sort of an
anxiety disorder,
but I know that he had to take them and
it's hard once you take them to get rid
of them.
I know a bunch of dudes that like need
them,
you know,
like people that have like any sort,
a back injury,
debilitating back injury and that you
get hooked on those bitches.
And they get you through the day.
I know a lot of people that just need
that man,
you know,
they need them.
It's just terrible.
And.
But what I was saying is the dudes that
I know that have had problems with pain
pills,
a lot of them were like really smart
guys that went to college.
They're not idiots,
you know?
Do you have the thing in front of my
face?
I'm moving.
I'm just going to show you this video in
a second.
Okay ma'am.
But you can't do that.
It's only been a second.
I've seen this.
I know I was going to talk about it.
Okay.
But why do you have it in front of my
fucking face?
I like looking at myself.
Well,
nobody knows what the fuck you're doing.
Yeah,
who cares?
It's a fucking webcasts do.
This is serious thing.
I totally forgot.
I was even talking about now what was
talking about.
Uh,
actually I was doing this.
You motherfucker.
Stupid Bullshit.
Tell me ladies and gentlemen,
what the fuck was I just talking about?
Huh?
Pretty crazy about that dog though.
And I heard that that video.
The dog in the video?
Yeah,
that was a dog that knew about the
earthquake before the people do.
That's because people hear shit.
They don't pay attention.
The dog heard something is probably what
the fuck.
And the person was like,
what the fuck is that shit?
He didn't react and then it happened
because it was only like a second before
it.
Here's that video right here.
Watch the dog.
It just freaked out and ran.
I mean,
but it was a while before even anything
shook.
Let's see it again.
Rewind it.
Here's the dog dogs chilling though.
I was like,
what the fuck is that noise?
Okay.
We don't know that.
That dude didn't react.
This is a stupid video,
but this is the problem the dog took off
running,
but the guy you don't see his face.
The guy might've went,
oh shit,
what the fuck?
And everybody is making it like the dog
heard this before anybody else.
But he felt some.
Because if you look at it but nothing's
moving at all.
Right?
But sometimes you hear things before the
earthquake.
Well you know that's true.
You know,
it doesn't really start moving until.
Let me see it again.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Shit moving.
Maybe it made a sound.
Yeah,
you're right on the ground to that.
It's kind of weird.
If there was a sound right,
a real rumble can still see some fingers
monitor.
So.
So the dogs like two second smarter than
a person.
But guess what?
We got thumbs.
Faggot.
Good.
Sure.
Down sleeping dirt.
All right.
What else were we talking about?
Folks?
We were talking about some important
shit and I forgot about God.
Damn.
We got a lot of twitter messages coming
in this pitch,
that mark mcgwire thing.
That thing is hilarious.
Mark Mcguire is finally coming out and
saying,
well that's what we were talking about.
We're talking about people that are
hooked on pain pills.
You know that.
It's a when when dudes get hooked on
pain pills,
like I said,
I know a guy who's a very smart guy.
He was an it guy,
went to uh,
you know,
went to college.
Really avid reader,
not a,
not a fuck up.
Has a real.
And
that's just what it is,
man.
Dudes.
Dudes get injured,
something happens to you and then adjust
it chemically bonds with your body.
I mean it's really incredible with what
addiction is,
you know,
conviction is your,
your body is somehow or another linked
to something that's really terrible for
it and it needs that.
Something like it becomes.
It's almost like like heroin and crystal
meth and stuff like that that really
locks a hold of your body.
It's almost like they're parasites.
It's almost like the drug itself has a
consciousness and the drug itself is
gonna make you do it as much as you can
and all and rob you of life.
You know?
I mean that's one way to look at like
horrible substances.
That's why when people talk about drugs,
you know,
and they like to lump all drugs in
together.
I love that.
That's so stupid because marijuana and
mushrooms and psychedelic drugs,
if done correctly,
can be very beneficial and when they're
over you don't feel any repercussions.
You're okay if they don't hurt you,
marijuana and mushrooms and things like
that.
The natural things that people have been
doing for tens of thousands of years,
those things aren't hurting anybody,
man,
and they can't get into your system,
you know,
and if you lump them in with oxycodones
and fucking heroin and crystal Meth,
that's ridiculous.
Don't want to.
It's becoming a more introspective,
fascinating person on crystal meth.
There'll become and fucking crazy.
It's like we have to look at drugs and
in terms of what they do to the people
that take them and do the things that do
positive things.
You can't ignore that just because
they're a drug.
You're not allowed to just say,
oh,
because it's an illegal drug than all
the benefits that people talk about it.
Those don't count.
They're invalid just because it's not
sanctioned by a group of fucking
criminals.
That's ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense at all.
And you know,
I've lived my whole life like this.
I mean it's 2010.
I would have thought by now we would
have come to some sort of irrational
understanding as human beings,
as we got to be adults.
I thought we would come to a point where
we would sit back and we would look at
things and go,
Whoa,
what?
What right?
Do I have to tell another person what to
do or not to do?
As long as he's not trying to give it to
minors or people that don't know any
better.
As long as people are educated,
let's spend money on programs and make
sure that people don't get involved in
anything fucked up like this and let's
pay attention to fucking children in
schools.
I mean,
the biggest problem this country isn't
laws and and crime.
The biggest problem is why are people
creating crime?
Why?
Why are people doing these terrible
things to each other?
90 nine point nine,
nine percent of all fucked up.
Things become out of a fucked up
childhood.
You have kids who have either a shitty
fucking parents and in these fucking
children,
they grow up and they're ticking time
bombs.
If you have a douchebag fucked up drug
addict parents and you live in a fucked
up place with no love and every day you
just see violence and Shit and screaming
and addiction and sorrow and there's no
way out.
You don't see shit.
You don't do well in school.
I mean what the fuck?
That is a ticking time bomb and for
politicians to not address that and to
spend all this fucking time flying over
to Afghanistan trying to chase down 100
Taliban fighters in the mountains and
young people are dying over there for
that help out.
We spend that money attacking the
fucking enemy at home.
The enemy at home is a horrible fucking
childhoods that some of our fellow human
beings in this country have to go
through.
You know,
what we really need to do is focus on
fucking kids.
Focus on children that are growing up in
terrible neighborhoods.
Focus on fucking schools and community
centers and give these kids somewhere to
go to when their parents suck.
You know,
focus on a bunch of people that want to
help raise kids that come from terrible
situations or help the parents
understand what the fuck they're doing,
raising children and,
and making these kids fucking psychos
and giving them horrible childhoods,
you know,
and then and literally setting loose a
bomb setting loose.
Someone who's eventually going to turn
all their,
their inward anger outward and other
people or other their pain and
resentment and all that.
The negative input coming into them as a
child,
you know that shit is fucking terrible.
You deal with a child,
the customer positive loving
environment,
and you're going to deal with a human
being that human beings going to come
out of that and going to appreciate
other people.
That's our number one problem.
As human beings,
our number one problem as human beings
is the way we don't appreciate each
other,
the way we look at each other as
competition,
the way we look at each other as just
people that are on the highway and my
fucking way.
Human beings have to learn to appreciate
each other and we need to learn how to
deal with the fucking very obvious shit
that we ignore instead of pretending
there's some incredible assault on the
human race here in America.
You know,
maybe we should look on what.
Where does the real crime coming from?
Are the real murders coming from where's
the real anger and violence and the shit
that affects day to day people everyday.
It's not the fucking desert.
Okay.
It's not the fucking mountains of
Afghanistan.
It's in cities.
It's all over the place.
It's,
it's children growing up and becoming
fucking criminals.
That's way scarier to me than some
Douche bag in Afghanistan.
You know?
It's nonsense.
Yeah.
Someone said Carl and pills.
That's something Carl's training partner
said,
but like I said,
I don't know if it's true.
Oh,
all I know is that he's a.
he's always been a cool dude to me.
Carl is a great fighter and he's got
some unfortunate situations and I hope
it works out.
I liked that too.
I'd like to do it a lot.
He's good people and he's a bad
motherfucker.
One of the best judo guys to ever enter
mma,
you know,
he uh,
he opened people's eyes to a lot of shit
that was possible because before caro
nobody was hitting like those beautiful
fucking throws.
He hits his beautiful shoulder throws
and hip throws and his,
his judo,
like back when he fought like Dave
Strasser,
like when it was first a UFC bounce.
Incredible judo,
you know,
and it's,
that's an whenever get a guy who steps
into mma and has some totally something
that he's really,
really good at that most people aren't
like,
like Machita with karate,
like people will crowd,
isn't that good?
Credit isn't really work until Machida
came along and were treated.
Machida is so good at karate.
Then he makes karate work in MMA,
you know,
obviously he knows wrestling and
obviously he knows all the other stuff
that goes with MMA,
which is why it's such a champion.
But the bottom line is his karate,
his ability to move backward.
I mean,
he fights like a fucking John Claude van
Damme movie and it's,
it's pretty bad ass to watch,
you know,
because until the shogun fight,
he really didn't take hardly any damage.
What do I think about the United Arab
Emirates buying to Suva?
Well,
I know that the guy who is behind it all
is a chic,
talked noon of uh,
uh,
Abu Dhabi and that guy is a huge fan of
mixed martial arts and he's incredibly,
incredibly wealthy.
So you know,
that guy can,
he can do a lot of good things for mma.
That guy,
he is a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt
under Henzel Gracie,
and by all accounts he's legit by all
accounts.
He's a really good black belt and Hanzo
is one of the most respected instructors
in the world.
If Henzel gracie gives you a black belt,
that's a huge honor.
So that she talked noon.
The fact that he's a Henzel gracie black
belt.
I know he's been having people travel to
Abu Dhabi for years,
for over a decade since the late
nineties and he had like some of the
best instructors in the world that would
come and stay with him and uh,
he had a whole camp there and you bring
guys and you have guys to train with.
I mean,
dude,
it's just the Jujitsu fiend just,
I mean like more than way more than me,
you know,
like,
I mean think about how much I love
Jujitsu and this guy is like,
you know,
he's just like,
he loves it and he has unlimited
resources.
So having a guy like that as a business
partner in the UFC I think is gonna be
phenomenal for the sport.
I don't think there's any question that
guy is going to without a doubt that God
is going to help out and it's going to
be interesting to go there.
That lives in a castle like a fucking
some old school out,
you know,
Ali Baba Type Shit,
right?
Yeah.
It's even one without the paintings now.
Who is the guy that I don't know the
sheik has like,
I think that the royal family is worth
like some insane amount of money,
like the one of the most richest people
in the world.
How about that one of the richest people
That dude is a fucking train killer.
Uh,
do I think is going to take an active
role like Dana White?
I have no idea.
All I do for the UFC is the commentary.
You know what I mean?
I talked to those guys and they're my
friends,
but obviously I've no,
no influence whatsoever on the business
side of things.
It's just my job to call the action.
It's a really pretty fucking crazy gig.
You know,
for me it's like a perfect job because
I'm a huge fan of mixed martial arts.
Like for real,
like I'm not,
I don't watch like when I watched the
different shows like k one or saying go
goo or you know,
dream or,
or a strike force or anything like that.
When I watch those shows,
I don't watch those shows for work.
I don't,
you know,
I don't get on the underground and mixed
martial arts that come or,
you know,
read all the bloody elbow,
read all these different websites and do
it just for,
for fun.
I would have done it even if I would
have done it,
even if it wasn't my job.
I'm just a huge fan,
like professionally and I'm very lucky,
you know,
it's pretty crazy gig man.
So a lot of fun.
It's cool too because we get to go to
the fights and you know,
be there live and be right in front of
the cage.
I mean it's just like there's nothing
like that.
What do you think of the last year?
I've seen some good fights,
man.
Did you see it?
Yeah.
That Evan Dunham,
dude,
how bad asses that guy.
And he got tagged in the first round,
the first round,
you know,
effort and was all over them.
And then Evan Dunham survived and pulled
off that.
That fucking Armbar was so bad ass.
The way did,
it was like,
it was so wicked.
Did he break his arm at all?
Uh,
no.
He did not break his arm.
He fucked up his tendons.
So lucky for him.
It was a.
The problem is man,
if it breaks,
if that.
The way that armbar happened,
see how his arm,
like he was bending it completely at the
joint is scary.
Kindness the way Frank Mir broke tim his
arm because he actually broke the middle
of the forearm.
He broke the forum and half.
That's the scary shit that takes forever
to heal and it's usually not the same.
They're like,
I don't think you know.
I think you break your arm like that,
man.
That's a serious fucking fracture.
Like in the middle.
I think if you bust up a joint,
they get put that together a little bit
easier.
Take arms and now by now you like metal
arms or bones or something,
but I don't think they can.
I think they,
they do hips and they do knees,
but once you get a knee that's a wrap.
You ain't doing no Jujitsu.
Well,
this dude named connor,
connor human,
he's a one of Eddie's top students,
a real high level wrestler and his dad
was a wrestler and his dad got a hip
replacement and his dad still does do
Jujitsu and fighting tournament and the
dude's like 50.
It's incredible,
you know,
but he has a hip replacement,
but he's a fucking psycho and he's a
stud.
You know the,
the average person,
you get a hip replacement and that's a
wrap.
You know?
Remember that dude from the Sopranos,
he used to walk fucked up.
The Fat Guy who turned out,
you know he's gay and the and the
Sopranos.
And he had that weird walk.
Do you remember that guy?
What was his name?
I don't remember that Kai's character.
I can't remember.
Something killed him.
Remember?
He was gay.
They murdered him.
I think they jumped like a fucking a
broomstick up his ass or a hundred
member pool.
Cue up his ass.
That's right.
Because he was selling a line of pool
cues.
After that,
the dude tried to sell a,
a pool cues acute to die for the bottom
break.
It was like a brake stick.
That's ridiculous,
but Sopranos told him to knock it off.
How hilarious is that as a dude?
Some marketing sense got killed.
A pool cue.
I'll show them those motherfuckers on
the qs sales pool cues because they
killed them with one of the Sopranos.
Greatest show of all time.
Right?
Oh,
I miss it.
Got Slower near the end,
but I still miss.
I,
you know,
I got into Battlestar Galactica for
awhile.
I like that up until the last season,
but the last season I just didn't give a
shit about.
Last is the only thing that really got
me.
Like this season I'm still really pumped
up to see what the fuck is going on
because I watched last.
I didn't watch it at all for like the
first whatever seasons there were the
first three or four seasons or whatever
it is.
How many seasons have they done?
Have they really?
Well,
I watched all of them from the beginning
to the end.
All of them on DVD,
which is the shit if you've,
if you've managed to avoid like Ari did
that with the Sopranos.
He didn't leave his fucking house,
our estate home for like weeks and just
watched the Sopranos Dvds watched the
whole series to the end.
Have you ever done that?
No.
Only with lost,
but I caught up to.
They're the ones that were on the Dvr
last year.
I did like the first three seasons,
the sopranos that way.
Oh yeah.
Seasons of Dexter.
I did that way to whole first season.
It's the way,
but there's another one out.
Last year I was like,
Eh,
this year,
this year rather,
as soon as I started watching,
I was like,
Eh,
I'm not in this anymore.
Or some dude killing people.
After awhile I'm like,
okay,
where are we going to go with this?
You know you're going to keep getting
away with this.
I'm Kinda keeps saying you kill the bad
guy every week.
Grayling,
come on man.
This is silly.
Did you see that break dancing robot?
Yes.
How awesome that.
How about that fuck robot they created.
You see that?
That's gross.
You see Jimmy Kimmel last night?
No,
I didn't say that.
He was dressed up as Jane line and I
heard it was hilarious.
They were talking about the mystery
here.
I'll say right now,
I wouldn't see this.
Jimmy Kimmel dressed up as a,
as Leno,
the fucking wars,
the war,
the war for late night.
Listen,
fuck.
Late night.
The Internet is where it's at.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the real connection to human
beings.
These silly shows where you sit down and
you know,
ask some fucking 16 year old kid what
are new CD is,
you know,
hey,
sign is standing.
You got a new shell out.
Oh,
that's terrific.
Who gives a fuck about all that stuff?
It's just you're just under the other.
There's just people in their pimp and
things.
People pimp and movies and occasionally
someone gives their dick sucked by some
crazy cooker or something like that.
Hugh grant interview and you'd get an
interesting interview or the other dude
that the,
the,
the.
What's his name?
Joaquin Phoenix that showed up.
All fucked up.
What happened in him?
Is He still fucking crazy?
I Dunno,
but Letterman is the best for taking
advantage of those situations.
And Joaquin Phoenix either was playing a
character,
you might've been just doing it for a
goof,
you know,
I could see him doing something or
saying it's real.
There's just gone,
completely gone.
It's not hard to do if you're a person
who wanted to be famous and you know,
your whole life you've wanted to be
famous and you've had,
you have this need,
this hyper need for attention.
And then all of a it happens to like,
Holy Shit,
you know,
I'm lucky that the kind of fame that I
got like always was.
Especially the fear factor thing was
like ridiculous fame,
you know,
like no one's kissing your ass for fear
factor.
You know,
when people come up to you for fear
factor,
like what the fuck dude?
And I'm a.
and I was like,
yeah,
I know what the fuck.
But it's not like they love,
you know,
like if you're like an actor or
something like that and you're in some
crazy movies,
like that guy is the kind of adulation
that guy must get.
It's insane.
You know?
And if he was already crazy to begin
with that just when,
when crazy people all of a sudden have
money and people kissing their ass,
you know,
crazy people are supposed to be like
suppressed.
Like you split the crazy people.
You supposed to see them and go,
hey fuck head,
you're crazy.
But that doesn't work like on the TV
show or a movie.
Because once you become crazy,
it doesn't matter if you're a star,
they let you be crazy.
So you're just plucking hog wild and
doing blow and punching people and they
try to protect you as much as possible
because you're the goose that lays the
golden egg.
And that's what happens to a lot of
actors.
That's where they get fucking nutty.
So where's this video here?
Wait,
Jay Leno.
Okay.
This is a Jimmy Kimmel from last night.
I guess he was making fun of Jay Leno
with you.
Megan find it.
He even did that.
Joe It.
And they can hear us too.
While this was planned.
I got to watch it over here because this
stupid things on how much the delay is
video and video is tight.
Sir.
You are correct.
Chance sparks.
Oh Wow.
This is from.
He's got makeup on and everything.
All my guy,
he's the backs in my opinion.
Me knowing that I'm taking over all the
shows and late night
music.
Great to be here on thing.
Always bumped Conan NBC today that said
I won't participate in the destruction
of the tonight show.
Fortunately though,
I will.
Jimmy Kimmel tonight.
He's gone.
Don't worry,
it'll be fine.
Or he picked up an endorsement.
Deal with Jenny Craig
here.
And then here's him,
uh,
with uh,
Chevy Chase.
Uh,
let's,
let's talk to people.
What I'm going to keep playing.
What is this one from headlines
really lame.
Find a headline from the paper and then
we present them to you,
the viewer.
And uh,
our first headline,
that's the list.
Vehicles may end drunk and driving.
And cigarettes.
Man,
lung cancer.
I should show you this one.
Here we go.
A service worker.
What are they usually hire?
Robots.
Service workers.
Oh my God.
Murdering medic.
What is the repair of your tornado?
What got you into trouble in the first
place
that's real.
Oh my God,
a Maltese and beautiful slowly,
very,
very slowly after the famous pilot
flowing flowing burger.
Wow.
That was brutal.
We're on like a 15 second delay is that
in case we commit suicide and it's just
probably what I'm doing over here.
It takes like 15 seconds to see what's
happening over there.
So if like you're watching someone in
the video and a werewolf is like
standing over there,
by the time you see that,
that motherfucker's dead where we'll
fuck that dude.
A long time ago was a big ass delay
here.
I wonder if like,
you know there's someone watching all
the controversial ustream ones and they
don't have a delay and they're like
right there with a finger on the button
if you do something nutty because then
the guy commit suicide on,
on a web web show.
A guy committed to kill themselves all
the time.
Now at least two people I think.
Well that's not all the time.
That's a big,
you know,
when the community is not,
we've got to do man.
We gotta do headphones.
That way we could listen to ourselves
and make sure that the sound is good and
now I'm watching them now what happened?
Watching meters.
Yeah.
Crazy motherfucker.
I'm glad we got this microphone to.
This is the perfect microphone,
right?
Because it picks up everything.
You could probably press pause and then
refresh your browser if you want to
catch up.
Really?
You think so?
Oh,
you're right.
You motherfucker
the Mar Gaydon wow.
That's,
that's more kate.
And do you know more cadence?
It's one of the best comics ever.
I don't think it's real anymore.
Come on man.
That's him,
dude.
He's been saying some crazy shit.
He's one of England's pride.
The pride of England.
He's pretty funny.
He's not as funny.
Well,
funny looking.
He's um,
you don't think he's a genius?
You don't get it.
You don't get the material.
I just think that,
uh,
I can't understand a word he says.
Hey.
Uh Oh.
It looks like this guy.
David Galloway.
G O e w e y says I'm up at 3:48
AM in Abu Dhabi.
Now answer some questions.
Joe Will.
Fuck.
Yeah,
dude,
I'll ask you some questions.
You're up at 4:00
in the morning and you live in Abu
Dhabi.
I got two questions for you sir.
What's it like over there?
Man?
I hear this all like fucking everybody's
got a Ferrari.
It's like one of the richest places in
the world.
I've heard it's fucking crazy.
Is that true?
So recitation real legal there.
I don't think prostitution is but I
think if you're like,
you know,
some sort of a ball or character.
I mean I think they just ignore it.
I mean the way it happens in Dubai,
it is like all the hookers just go
there.
They just know all the rich guys are the
rich guys go to Dubai.
So hookers was coming from everywhere
and I think they just ignore it,
you know?
I don't know though.
I don't think it's legal.
Is there any questions on your message
board?
But I don't,
I've never been either will go to the
message board shortly,
but I want to hit.
I want to see what this guy has to say.
It is sweet.
And he says,
David Wood.
David,
you just chilling in Abu Dhabi.
What do you do out there,
man?
What do you do for a living in Abu
Dhabi?
Do you have a Ferrari?
Do they give you one?
You get your driver's license.
They'd hit you.
Do you like the yellow or the red?
You can get a black one too.
If you know somebody
do do,
do,
do.
Alright.
I'm going to go to some questions here.
Let's do two girls,
one cup video in video that kind of
says,
yeah,
I was thinking about.
Has Anybody not seen two girls?
One Cup though?
I was really going to shoot a horse
wine.
Oh,
you guys want to see Mr Han's.
We can't do that.
That was upbeat.
US broadcasting of ABC.
Okay,
but then we can't show the shitty thing
either.
Can we not?
We can't do anything like that can be
automatically banned.
All right.
Listen folks,
this is going to.
We're going to do this for a little bit,
but eventually we're going to move over
to my website so I could show you guys
getting fucked.
Death by horses and people eat shit.
I did not know that.
I was not able to show those types of
videos.
Well this is not going to last.
They let us say whatever they want,
whatever we want,
but we can't show you whatever we want,
which I don't think is
going to be any of the stream websites.
You won't be able to like,
well,
we're going to have to either talk to
you stream and see if we can say yes to
that.
No,
no one will.
Yeah.
Because even if you say like if you
click on something saying that you are
18 and over,
we don't have that.
Now do we?
Do we have that now where they have to
click on something that says there are
18 and over.
We should have that.
I think that's possible.
People probably put it on there.
Well,
there's definitely do that.
I don't want any little kids getting a
shitty ideas.
I don't want to have to explain anything
to.
It's not that I'm telling you anything
that's not correct.
It's just that I don't want to have to
sit down with you and go over the way.
The world really works.
It's too much work with this guy says
Alexander wrote says he heard this
Ferrari's just abandoned in the street.
That's what I'm talking about,
man.
Motherfuckers got money.
It's like,
what does that 2007 just piano throw the
keys inside the.
They give them away to goodwill and
raise her phones everywhere.
You're mowing the lawn and there's razor
phones.
Just finding out hitting.
I think they have lungs,
man.
Our guys are.
I would like to see.
Maybe they do.
Maybe they turned into.
Well,
I think they're going to have an outdoor
fight.
They're really exploring the place.
That's really scary.
The Middle East is in a strange land
man.
It's a strange land.
Very different.
Yeah.
For the people that want to see Mr
Hanson and want to know what I'm talking
about.
Go to a two guys.
One horse,
one.com.
Two guys.
One horse.com
is the video that I wanted to show you,
but I can't because you stream or a
bunch of pussies.
I guess they want to make money.
You don't want to pee.
Advertisers pull it out like they do
with tiger woods.
Pour for poor tiger was a fella I,
uh,
went to the airport and they still have
his posters up for accenture,
one of the first companies that dropped
him and one of the posters,
it's tiger looking like,
you know,
contemplating a shot and it says
something like,
it's what you do next.
That counts.
Put it up on my twitter page.
I'm like,
man,
how fucking telling is that?
Did he ever have a fucking inkling of a
clue that that's what was gonna happen
when he put that picture out?
And people are like,
people freak out about the tiger woods
thing like that.
He's a terrible person.
And he said,
yes,
it's not the best thing to do.
I agree.
But that guy is an,
an handsome.
He's an unfortunate looking guy.
He's very unfortunate looking and he's a
fucking billionaire.
He's got super,
super rich dude.
I bet it was impossible for him to say
no dollars checks,
you know?
I mean,
if you think,
I mean obviously it was a pussy hound.
I mean there's no getting away from
that.
But to be like that guy you know and
have all these tens and they're chasing
you down and they don't even care if
you're married and they'll fly to other
countries to hang out with you.
Holy Shit.
You know,
it's like a rock star.
He's totally like a rock star and it
will then you shouldn't be married.
I totally agree.
I'm not defending him in any way.
He's more of a rockstar.
Most rock stars don't have own beverage.
Then
they'll have their own clothing line.
That dude,
it's fucking crazy.
People love that stupid ass game.
They love it.
Especially business people.
If you want to get down to business,
you know,
I've heard a lot of people say that if
you want to be successful in business,
that you literally have to learn golf.
Like you literally have to learn it.
If you don't learn golf,
that he hit refresh
screen,
show you so you can see why it sat.
What's going on?
It's gone on inside.
Just a picture.
That picture you're talking about tiger
woods.
Oh,
what's wrong with this then?
I don't know.
I mean,
when you stream,
you're sucking it dummies.
I would close your firearm
and open up like in safari or chrome,
maybe have twins.
Shit Open.
No,
there it goes.
It's usually the pictures up filing.
See,
that's much much of a delay.
So like I said,
if you see a werewolf behind me and you
hear that,
believe me,
I'm already dead.
Okay.
Just be kind to be on the message
boards.
People are brutal about Artie Lange.
Man.
That was really sad to see how many
people were brutal after already laying
tried to commit suicide.
Like calling them people just like that
suicide shit.
All right.
I know,
but it wasn't just that.
It was,
it was.
There were,
there were insulting him.
Like it didn't matter.
You know,
you know that he's weak and he's a piece
of shit.
Like I said about where it talked about
the people that I know that have had
problems with pain pills.
It's not like,
you know,
the guy likes to jerk off,
he jerks off.
Two months later,
that guy.
You need to smack him in the head and
go,
what the fuck is wrong with you?
You lost your job because you jerk off
five times a day.
You know there's dudes like that.
They're like,
dear ms.jobs.
They,
they,
they show up late for work just because
they're like chronic masturbator.
They wake up in the morning,
they have to beat off.
They don't beat off.
They're going to go crazy.
Like they get that.
That's a dude that's got a problem.
That guy's his.
He needs a smack in the head.
People that are like,
like compulsive gamblers.
That's a compulsion and that's there
though.
There's a problem and your pattern of
thinking,
there's a problem in the way,
you know,
and I've been compulsive about many
things in my life.
I understand what it is,
I understand the thinking behind it,
but that could all be corrected.
You just need to learn how to think
correctly.
There's a big difference between that
and like heroin and Oxycontin and math
and people who get addicted to shit.
That shit's real.
That's real.
You know?
So to get to shit all over someone
because they're addicted to a drug man,
it ain't easy to kick that.
You don't,
you know,
unless you're doing it,
unless you're deep in the throes of
heroin,
you can't talk shit.
And if you have been,
and I haven't,
so I can say nothing,
but I've talked to people who have.
I had a friend who,
who died from heroin.
I knew a couple people that die from
heroin.
And uh,
the one that I knew he was,
he was a real,
real smart guy.
He was,
he was a cool dude.
He just couldn't stop it.
I don't know.
I don't.
I think some people bond to those
dangerous drugs and you're fucked.
So whatever happened with him already
laying was every time I met that guy,
he's always been cool to.
And that's how I judge people.
He's always fun to be around,
friendly,
jovial,
and he's,
I think he's hilarious.
He's just a,
he's a nice guy,
you know,
and to me it just made me sad.
It made me just the sound of the people
were willing to shit on this guy because
he tried to kill himself,
but you are right.
People get mad when people try to kill
themselves,
you know,
especially when people have a much
better life than them.
You know?
I mean,
that was the argument that I heard over
and over again about already like this
fucking guy.
You know,
what are his problems?
He's got a Mercedes and you know he's
rich and all true,
but that doesn't make you feel better.
Unfortunately you'd think it would,
but it doesn't.
If your life sucks,
your life sucks and it really has
nothing to do with you.
Being rich or poor.
Rich can definitely help things because
you don't have to worry about your bills
and you have less problems.
You have a little bit less stress,
but then you've got problems with your
money and investments and people
stealing from you and bullshit.
You know,
you.
Yeah,
you have problems all over the place.
Definitely better to have it than not,
but the bottom line is just because
you're successful doesn't mean you're
happy.
There's a lot of people that are fucking
horribly hard,
horribly depressed,
and they sit around thinking,
well,
what the fuck is the purpose of his
life?
You know,
and the real problem is,
that's a good goddamn question.
What is the purpose of this life if
you're not here for other people,
what are you here for?
Because realistically,
you know,
you get to a certain point in your life
like already and I are basically the
same age.
I'm 42 and I believe he is too.
And you know,
you get to a point where you're like,
you get all this gray like have gray
hair and my beard and on my balls I have
like 20 gray hairs.
So gray hairs coming in here.
I mean this is like,
you know,
your body's dying.
So at a certain point in time you got to
go,
what the fuck is the purpose of all
this?
What am I here for?
You know,
and if you don't have like a
relationship,
you don't have someone you love,
you don't have really good friends that
you love and you love to be around.
You don't have a family,
you don't have children,
you don't have someone that that you
mean something to someone that you feed
off of each other and you share energy
and you make them feel good and they
make you feel good.
You know they miss you and you miss
them,
and that's very,
very,
very important for people and people
just underestimate how huge that is.
You know,
having friends and having family and
having good quality people in your life
and not douchebags cut the Douche bags
out.
That is so important because nothing can
fuck your life up more than people who
are not looking out for your best
interest and want you to fail because
they're fucked up.
You know?
Try to let them aware it,
let them be aware of it,
give them an opportunity to change and
if they don't get rid of a condom out of
your life.
So important,
just separate yourself from anybody
negative that's going to fuck with you.
That can make such a huge difference in
the quality of your life.
You know?
And then of course,
get the fuck away from drugs.
The bad ones,
don't fuck around with heroin.
Don't fuck around with math.
Don't fuck around with anything
dangerous.
If you're going to do something,
do,
do things that people have never died
from,
and make sure you know what the fuck
you're doing before you do it.
You know,
don't go crazy and smoke the whole joint
the first time you know you shit your
pants and paranoia.
You freaked the fuck out,
Yo.
You're probably never going to get high
again.
The first time you ever get high and you
should just get a little tiny bit high.
Just a little tiny bit of a hit and get
used to it.
You know,
it's like riding a surfboard.
You can't just hop on.
You'd be awesome at it.
No know the feeling of being caught up
in the wave of thc when,
when when you get really high,
it's like you're connecting to like
another,
another frequency that it's not
available to you when you're sober and
that's where people don't smoke
marijuana.
Don't understand.
There's an awareness and opening of your
mind,
and I've had explained to me chemically
about Gaba and dopamine and all the
different things that go on.
There was a recent threat about it on my
message board where people are talking
about the effect of it,
but the bottom line is it does something
to the way you think and it opens up new
levels of awareness and if you get too
much of that,
you're going to freak the fuck out,
and that's called being paranoid.
But what paranoia comes from is this
probably the first time you're
recognizing reality.
You know you're a very vulnerable
person.
We all our life is,
is you know,
it's a transient experience.
It's gonna.
You're gonna pass from this to something
else.
Maybe.
Who knows?
Who knows what the fuck.
This is the first place.
Who knows what the ultimate goal of
human racist in the first place.
You just live your life and go through
it and you put your blinders on and when
you have a hit of some really good weed,
those blinders just fall down around you
and you realize like,
wow,
I'm this fragile,
fleshy little temporary being that's
plaguing to the spinning orb has it's
flying through the galaxy and people are
sitting around talking about John and
Kate and,
and,
and fucking Miley Cyrus and nonsense.
And while this is all going on,
were hurling through the galaxy and then
literally is never discussed.
You know,
and I have a bit about it.
You can see it on youtube.
I think it's somebody put it up,
it's yours.
It's from my,
uh,
my,
shiny happy Jihad CD.
It's about flying through space,
but that's where we are.
I mean,
we're,
we're just,
we're just animals clinging to a sphere
in eternity in this gigantic sea of
eternity,
sea of space.
This never ending thing that we're a
part of,
but we completely ignore and we focus on
the most mundane bullshit.
Like Tiger Woods,
fucking all these girls,
you know.
And like what else,
what are the other dumb shit that people
have been focusing on lately in the
news?
I know,
I think why people focus on so much and
it's because you know,
they need something.
It's like kind of watching the same
movie over and over again.
You know,
you need constant new information and
stuff like that,
you know,
like I understand what you're saying
like about the whole thing.
But uh,
I think that's why so many people
focused on the dumb shit because the new
shit,
you know,
that same thing.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
So like what you're saying is that the
reason why people focus on like tiger
woods and stuff like that,
it's just because it's new information.
It doesn't matter.
We've been in space for so long and
nothing happens
and you look up,
you see stars while Blah Blah,
shut the fuck up.
It's like same cell phone.
What would you have the same stuff on
for 10 years?
Or if tiger woods sell new cell phone
came out,
would you get the tiger woods and stuff?
That's a good point.
I think Brian's onto something.
I think know,
I mean it makes sense because you know,
people are,
we do,
we have this push for new things and
innovation and it's literally built into
our hard wiring,
which is why you can take a guy with the
hottest chick in the world and he
doesn't want to fuck her anymore.
So like you get,
you get tired of fucking the hottest
chick in the world and that really is
true.
You know that that can happen.
Yeah.
If you look at life the wrong way and
that's one of the other things that's
awesome about weed.
If you smoke weed and you fuck your
girlfriend,
like if you,
if you don't usually do that,
it's like you're fucking a new person.
It's like you appreciate are all for
like who she is and what she,
what she looks like.
You appreciate it all over again.
It's really weird,
man.
At least for me.
Do you feel like that when you smoke
weed and get with your lady?
Yeah.
When you smoke weed and get with your
lady.
My lady doesn't really smoke weed so
it's not really that fun.
Well,
mine can't right now because she's
pregnant with me.
Bambino.
So have you played with the nexus one
yet?
No,
I have not.
You're not a fan,
huh?
Nah,
not really.
Michael Tech Review Ladies.
Gentlemen to.
The main problem is,
is if you have something like we both
have iphones and you have facebook and
twitter and all these applications.
Why I've had droid.
Why have an inferior version of facebook
on the droid sucks the twitter on the
droids.
Not as good as twitter to,
you know,
everything is just the blackberry.
And I have uber,
twitter on it.
I use,
um,
I have an iphone but okay.
I really
use it more of,
as like a,
um,
like a,
like a laptop that I keep in my pocket.
That's really what it is for me because
the bottom line with the iphone,
it's,
it's on a t and t and a t.
and t sucks when,
when I'm talking to people on a t and t
I can guarantee it's going to cut out
three or four times before I get
wherever the fuck I'm going.
When I drive in my car.
I love the fact that I can have both
hands on the steering wheel and I can
just talk,
you know,
and I'm having conversations and I can,
do business and answer questions and
catch up with old friends that I don't
have a chance to catch up with.
I love that,
man.
That's been huge to me.
To me,
that's one of the most important
features of communication,
the ability to fucking talk to somebody.
I don't like text messaging just back
and forth after a while,
man.
You're like,
I want to hear your fucking voice,
you know,
that's,
that's the way I like talking to people.
You know,
it's fun.
you can get things out of you,
feed off of each other.
You know,
it's,
it's a volley,
you're going back and forth.
So if your fucking phone can't make
phone calls,
that's weak.
That's weak shit.
So I use a blackberry with verizon.
No one's paying me to say this,
but the reason why I use the blackboard,
because uh,
we do a UFC is in the UK and the only
way you could get a,
um,
a phone that works overseas got to get a
world phone because we have two
different systems here in America.
We have CDMA and GSM and GSM is t mobile
and a t and t and a CBMA is sprint and
verizon and there are two totally
different types of signals.
Well,
in other countries,
most other countries don't use the CDMA,
which verizon has,
but it's the best in America and in
America it's the shit.
It's way better.
I mean,
I,
when I drive to Jujitsu,
I would lose people three times with my,
at and t phone three fucking times would
drive me crazy.
But my verizon was right there.
That never drops off for a second.
It's so much better.
But the bottom line is this shit is
whack.
This,
this,
this phone is like an iphone from 20
fucking years ago.
That's what it's like.
It's like some,
some cheap knock off,
you know,
like some third world country,
where they make fake watches and shit
like that.
I try to summarize are pretty nice.
The flashes are pretty nice.
Yes.
The cameras dope.
The uh,
the flash is very good.
The video is excellent.
Yes.
Reddit texting videos.
Excellent.
Is Not bad to type on the uh,
the typing.
This is the new one.
The storm to the double clicking is not
bad.
It's not just dropped in the toilet.
There's,
this was right next to my pool,
but it's job while I was at the 9:30
club in Washington DC,
by the way.
I had a good fucking time down there in
DC.
People.
Thank you very much for your
hospitality.
Awesome.
Awesome show.
I had a great time.
But anyway,
I was at the 9:30
club this Friday night and I was pulling
my pre-performance Poopoo and uh,
I got up and this phone because I was
called a piece of shit committed,
committed suicide and dove from my
pocket into the shitty toilet.
It's like,
I'll show you a piece of shit is trying
to kill data.
I know what it's doing because it knows
that I haven't backed up in a couple of
weeks,
has tried to go.
I've got some cool pictures and videos
on here and there's motherfuckers trying
to kill himself.
And uh,
so I got it out and shook it and shook
all the water out.
But I tried it with a hairdryer and the
bitch came back.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a great.
It's works tire.
Listen to your Shit Joe Rogan.
It's terribly for anything else.
When you try to go on the Internet,
you want to shoot yourself,
you try to use the twitter function on
here it's so clunky and whack and typing
is much.
It's okay to type like texts,
but when you have to type in numbers you
have to like really constantly this
little tiny ass keyboard where the
numbers are and you're always fucking
up.
Like when I have to give someone,
if I'm answering an email and I have to
give,
give someone an address or a phone
number,
it takes five minutes because I barely
can press down the three.
I'm also,
I'm always getting the number right next
to it.
It's,
it's really weakened and knowing.
So the iphone is shit.
It's just so goddamn far above every
else,
every other phone out there.
It's not even close.
If you're thinking about you want one
phone,
if you only had to choose between one
you got to go with the iphone.
But if you can afford to have two
phones,
the iphone is great for like a little
computer to me it's shoes for pictures
and twitters and applications and going
on.
I'd probably wait until after the apple
announcement in two weeks though,
is that there's a verizon iphone.
If there's a verizon iphone,
I'll fucking jump for joy,
but I don't think there's going to be
one.
We think that the verizon thing,
what we've read online,
because we're both Brian and I are both
tech retards.
The late verizon thing is,
uh,
probably going to be some sort of a
tablet,
like a little,
like an internet,
like a kindle,
but you can get on the Internet with
which would be kind of interesting,
like a,
like a netbook with no keyboard or just
an oversized iphone pretty much ever
heard or upgrade the gray.
Yeah,
he's that guy.
He's a guy from England that is a,
a professor and a scientist who's
working hard on a life extension.
He's an interesting dude,
kind of A.
I'm kind of a real eccentric character
with crazy long beard and he's got all
these really complex theories on how to
extend the human lifetimes,
like a thousand years.
But the only way you would die as if you
had a,
you know,
like got an accident or something or
sickness.
Pretty Fascinating Shit.
The problem is if people live forever,
there's not enough room for everybody.
You know,
we're trying to fuck with nature.
nature has us in a cycle and the cycle
is very simple.
Nobody lives more than like 120 years.
If you're the baddest motherfucker ever,
you live to be a buck 20 and then you're
done and the last few years you are a
fragile mess and you better not go
anywhere.
You know you could tie your shoes and
break your back in half.
You know you could fall down.
You know when you're going to wipe your
ass and head plant into the wall and be
done.
Crack your neck paralyze shell over the
floor.
I mean that could be the end.
It's going to be ugly.
You know you're going to be a human
role,
a tissue paper.
That's what you're going to be.
So that's,
that's the cycle of life.
You know,
and you have children and those
children,
you,
you pass on your information and that's
what's supposed to happen.
We are in the,
in the active process of evolving as a
species and there's two things that are
going to aid that involvement or
evolvement rather that evolution.
It's going to be either technology or
it's going to be what we learn and what
we pass on.
And if you don't evolve,
and if you don't pass on something,
if your children don't evolve like this,
race can't exist from just the people
that are alive now living forever.
Okay?
Because people don't change that much.
They,
they try,
they do their best.
But the amount of people that change
over the amount of people that don't
change,
I mean Shit,
how many people do you know that get
their shit together,
that have gotten their shit together?
They didn't have it.
You know,
how many people do you know,
not many.
Not that many.
Most people who are a fucking mess stay
a mess.
And that's not good.
Those aren't good odds for a whole race
of humans.
You know,
I think that the best bet for the human
race that we're really care about it as
a whole.
But we don't.
We care about ourselves because we're
animals and because we have these
instincts in these instincts are
designed to make sure that we stay alive
and you know,
and that's just hard wiring even though
your,
your logic and your reason would
dictate,
well,
Hey,
I'm only here for a temporary amount of
time anyway.
I need to look at this like what is my
purpose here?
What am I supposed to be doing?
And what you're supposed to be doing is
making it better for the next people
will you to be doing is making it as
good as you can for the people here and
leaving an impression so that maybe you
can enhance the minds and the open the
eyes and set the tone for the next
people.
You know,
if you meet a guy who's like,
I mean every time I've ever met someone
who's like really fucking cool and
really nice and really friendly,
it has always inspired me to be cooler
and nicer and friendlier.
It's like,
it's so cool to meet people like that.
But you know,
when I was growing up in Boston,
I knew a lot of fucking hard ass people.
I knew a lot of people that were just
always ready to insult you and always
wanted to fight and I knew a lot of.
And if you grow up around a lot of
people like that,
you,
you become like that.
Like it can make you like that you live
in that environment where everybody's
kind of Douchey to each other on
occasion,
you know,
like you go out to a bar in Boston,
your chances are you're going to see a
fight.
You go to a nightclub and Boston to
still throw down.
I mean,
it's one of the few places,
like,
remember when we went to at least do
the,
um,
common connection and faneuil hall and
after the show at like 2:00
in the morning,
that fucking place would be alive in the
summertime.
It was crackling.
Like at any moment you could see a
fucking brawl breakout where dudes punch
somebody and fucking tables would start
flying.
I mean,
it was a crazy place.
I would hate to look at.
Yeah,
I mean we,
I'm going to fight,
so we see them,
we saw so many fights and so many close
fights.
Me and Ram has got in a fight at
Mcdonald's.
Just waiting in line for the dudes are
way more aggressive in Boston than like
say if you go out and try to get some
something eat in Texas,
you know,
people are generally pretty fucking
friendly.
Like everybody has this,
like a stereotype of Texas,
but you're way safer going out to get
some late night food in Texas.
Especially like Austin Shit.
Austin's bad ass.
That's one of the friendliest fucking
cities in the country.
You know,
you want to go get something to eat at
2:00
in the morning and Austin,
you're fine.
She'll go get something to eat at 2:00
in the morning in Boston.
You might see a fucking assault,
you know,
you might be a part or something.
You got to watch where the fuck you're
gone.
Yeah.
Okay,
please.
Gentlemen,
we're going to go to the questions.
Do you do,
there's gotta be something you're not
looking forward to about fatherhood.
Well,
I'm already a father.
I love it.
You know what you don't look forward to
is you,
you,
you don't look forward to the fact that
you're going to lose a lot of your time.
You without a doubt,
you're going to have to spend.
If you don't want to be a shitty parent,
you know if you've had a childhood that
was less than perfect,
which I think most of us have,
right you,
you learned from that and you're
supposed to be a better person and a
better parent from that and once you
have a fucking kid,
man,
it's like,
all right,
you have this in immense,
immense responsibility to raise a human
being correctly and you've got to get
your own shit together.
You know it,
it forces you and you're going to
definitely have to look at things a
little bit differently because you're
not gonna have the same amount of free
time and you can't look at yourself like
you're the only thing you know.
That's what I was talking about before
with like a lot of people that I know
that aren't happy.
One of the reasons why they're not happy
is they don't have people in their life,
you know,
like that are really important.
You know,
like I know dudes that are like grown
man that don't even have like really,
really close friends.
They have friends,
but they're like keep shit from them and
you know,
sometimes they get bad arguments with
them and they don't,
they don't have anybody that they really
open up and are 100 percent honest with,
which is really huge.
You know,
if you don't have like a real friend
that you could fucking tell everything
to,
you got to have those in your life.
Man.
Those are huge when we're all out.
Like when it's me and Brian and Eddie
and Joey and we're all out bullshit and
we tell each other basically everything,
you know,
that's one of the fun things about it.
You know,
one of the fun things about hanging out
with people that you really like is,
you know,
you get to see inside each other.
It's fucking the wiring under the board.
You get to see how your brain works.
You know,
you get to throw out the way you're
thinking and what's going on in your
life to them and see how you know a
person who's not living your life but
loves you and looks out for you and
wants you to be happy.
He gets to look at it and see it,
and that's very important for people
because sometimes you can't see your
life objective,
Lee.
Sometimes you need somebody in your life
that that cares about you,
and when people don't have that shit,
they don't feel like they have that 100
percent honesty with someone.
You already are disconnected to the
universe and that's one of the reasons
why people get so depressed.
You know you're depressed because you
don't have all this love in your life.
You have to have a lot of love and you
have to put it out there too.
If you're putting out shit,
you're going to get shit back and then
you're going to get into a downward
spiral that you'd ever gonna to put out.
Pull out of.
You're going to have a shitty life.
You're putting out bad energy.
It's always coming back at you.
You're gonna,
you're always going to be unlucky.
You're always going to be unhappy.
It's just the way it is.
If you're an asshole,
you're not going to be happy assholes.
They look like they're happy because you
see them laughing.
They go home and cry and drink or their
fucking psycho and they have no emotions
whatsoever,
but no one is happy being negative.
Everybody wants to be loving.
Everybody wants to have good friends and
have a good fucking time.
So this operator,
Greg,
you're not going to live forever,
bitch,
and you're not supposed to.
You're supposed to do what you can to
the people that you,
it,
you influence and touch in this life and
hope that it carries on into the next.
And we all know this,
we all know that,
know this inherently and we all know
inherently that people have done this to
us.
You know,
like I said,
we've all met people that have inspired
us.
And uh,
I think that's what we're here for.
I think that's what,
uh,
that's what we're supposed to do.
It's just going to cover what are you
playing?
Shit.
While I'm doing this,
while I'm talking.
What is this robot?
Why you playing distracting shit.
Let me know when you're playing shit.
Tell me what it is.
Okay.
It's hard to read the questions off here
man.
Any plans for a book?
Yeah,
I'm,
I'm writing a book man.
But the problem is I'm writing comedy at
the same time and I'm also writing blog
entries and I'm also trying to do all my
other bullshit so it's some time,
you know,
it's hard to sit down and just write a
book because I sit down and write things
and I just want to write about one thing
that day and then I like,
that's what I like about blogs.
I can just write it,
throw it up and Bam,
there it is.
But I'm always looking for new ways that
people could listen to my shit,
get my ideas out there and get my stuff
out there and kids come to see me doing
standup and you know,
the different ways to do that.
You know,
it's like book books are legitimate.
Wayne's they're wasted.
There's still a lot of people that don't
even have any idea that I'm a stand up
comedian,
you know,
just because I like stuff that I've done
that's not funny,
like fear factor and whatever and you
know,
and doing commentary for the UFC,
it's the same thing.
It's like there's a lot of people that
really have no idea that I'm even a
comedian so I try to like do the best I
can to use all of the different avenues
to get that out there.
So I think a book is going to help.
And also I think it'd be cool to have
something that I actually wrote that
book,
you know,
I just think having a real book in the
bookstore is something cool about that
book.
Takes lots of concentration,
smoke more weed.
That's excellent advice.
I almost always write stoned,
you know,
and it might not make sense.
The problem is greed it when I'm not
stoned.
I'm like,
what the fuck was I rambling about when
I'm high?
It's all like super genius Shit Dude.
Dude.
Yeah.
I was talking about depression and
Brian's playing a fucking robot video.
Trying to lighten the mood,
Joe.
We don't need that man.
Is Jason Ellis the best radio show to go
on?
Opie and Anthony is the best radio show
to go on.
Jason Ellis is a close.
Second pitch was fun as fuck.
Jason's cool shit.
He's a.
he's hilarious too.
I love listening to him.
He's just a,
he's cocky and he's funny and I just uh,
he's a cool dude.
I like him a lot.
I like that guy.
He's fun.
Too many guys in Boston where in
affliction tee shirts.
Well there's nice people that were
affliction tee shirts to sir.
I goof around a fluxion tee shirts all
the time,
but I were there.
Shit.
I bought their jeans.
I bought their dragon jeans.
You're awful.
The genes are.
Genes are little much,
but I got some dope ass.
Um,
these uh,
Japanese.
He's a Samurai ones from affliction does
this shit man.
The whole,
the whole like a mythical,
uh,
it's,
I think it's called heroes and demons.
It's bad ass.
It's like Samurais flight and tigers and
shit.
And it's really cool art.
But there's a Japanese tattooist but
they don't make them anymore.
But I told Tom Tom Selection like those
shirts and shit.
I love them.
I used to,
before I smoked weed,
I used to dress terrible.
I think address bad now
have leopard print stripes,
structured shirts with like I used to
where things were really.
I used to wear like crushed red velvet
shirts and crazy.
But I'm not choking crazy big Hawaiian
shirts.
I'm a fashion retard.
Like I always have been,
you know.
And that's why I still wear a fanny
pack,
like her wear a fanny pack all the time,
you know,
whenever we travel I wear a fanny pack
and a belt chain.
Yeah.
And my chain,
my wallet chain.
Okay.
The wall chain,
you know,
watch there.
I've lost my wallet before.
I don't want to lose my wallet again.
Bam.
I got a wallet chain.
Nope.
I like it.
I like it too because a imperial rose
collection.
My man,
David Tademan,
he made it for me.
He said to me,
this dude's that's really cool dude.
Who's a big MMA fan?
Who's a jeweler?
And He sends me,
so to me it has power.
It's like a gift from somebody,
you know.
So it's this cool chain that I like.
It gives me strength and I liked it.
I'm not gonna lose my fucking wallet
again.
People are stupid.
You feel good for to.
You go to bed with her tonight.
I like wear my baseball hat backwards.
I like having a wallet chain.
If you think I look silly,
could make fun of me.
I don't care how have you gone without
wearing the lock chain from like I've
never.
I've waited a while chain for decades
and that's what I can't remember the
last time.
I didn't wear a wild chain when I was on
fear factor.
They used to make me tuck that shit in.
And it's weird because there's not many
of you,
you know,
there's not many wallet chain diesels.
I don't give a fuck.
I like it.
Do you ever run into any other wallet
team?
Would use a little compliment each other
on small chains.
They'll do dudes look at the chain of.
Yeah,
that's pretty bad ass man.
And Dana White Gimme a dope ass one,
so I wonder if you send it to you if you
would have a laugh.
Dana White's given me to wallet chains.
That's so cool.
Dana white is.
But this is the one that I use now and I
can't wait.
I can you see it?
Yeah,
I like it because it's a.
it's all like handcrafted mass.
A little dragon head and the little
dragon head opens up and that clips on
my belt.
Has it changed?
Is Dope chain.
It's really cool.
And for whatever fucking reason.
Okay.
This shit is metal as fuck,
but it does not go off when you go
through the metal detector.
I was stupid.
Or metal detectors.
I will fucking kill you with this.
A tripod on the plane,
but you can have a fucking chain.
Yeah,
I this thing,
this thing goes right through the metal
detector.
It's weird.
It's crazy.
I mean you really have to think like
that.
I mean,
I hope I shouldn't have opened my mouth.
Retards from TSA is watching this,
those fucking knuckle heads.
Some of them are cool.
I ran into a lot of cool people at the
airport,
but the laws is what's not cool.
None of it makes any god damn sense.
You know,
put a Goddamn comp on a plane,
on every plane.
Don't they already do that already?
Well,
not every claim.
She can't bring a pool cue on.
You could bring a skateboard,
but you can't bring a pool cue and a
laptop.
You can have a big Mac and you could
have a laptop that you designed
purposely to free people up.
Totally.
Yeah.
It's totally worth it.
Shut up before we and making sure we get
it all taken.
So how is Washington?
Washington was bad ass.
Washington DC show shows.
Great man.
We were at this place called the 9:30
club.
That's where I told you my phone fell
and toilet.
Awesome.
Awesome crowd.
Really?
I don't get to dc very much and they.
The last time I was there before we was
with John Heffernan,
Charlie Murphy when we did the maximum
comedy tour.
So you're in Miami Beach,
Florida next week,
right?
Yeah.
I'm in Miami Beach,
Florida on the 22nd.
Which is what is that,
and if I was looking at right now it is
a front page writer who will put the
little calendar on Youtube.
Yeah.
So next Friday.
But Bam motherfuckers,
that's another place I'm not at very
often.
None.
Florida very often.
Not in Miami very often,
but I'm here Friday pictures actually
fund that comedy Shit.
I guess there's going to be a lot of
people in town for that.
You're making a lot of comics are going
to be in town for that.
Yeah.
That sounds cool.
Awesome.
Powerful comedy festival.
And uh,
tickets are selling really fast.
So if you want to go,
I'm a go to where they were fucking uh,
uh,
I think that one is.
Do we have a lake somewhere?
Yeah.
You know what,
I'm going to throw the link on twitter
because I'm such a bad ass bitch.
That's what I was going to talk to you
about.
What?
Uh,
it's through live nation said you're
going to live nation.com.
Each ticket they are charging 17 like
something crazy,
like $15.
Like live nation,
get to cut service,
charge $15 service charge for three
tickets.
Some was saying that he was paying
something like insane,
like 200 bucks or something.
Yeah,
go check it.
Let's actually do it.
Well,
you know,
that's one of the things I like about
like a regular goddamn comedy club or
regular comedy club was the ticket cost.
Twenty five bucks.
You walk in the door and you pay your 25
bucks and that's it man.
You know?
Or if you show up early you can go to
the box office or you can order online.
You just buy it from the club and that's
what it costs.
You go through an agency,
but if you're going to do like a big
concert or something like that,
you have to go through an agency that's
another world.
You know,
once you start doing like big venues
started doing like several thousand
people.
That's,
that's a totally different world.
That's why I love comedy clubs.
That's first of all the shows better.
The shows are always better when it's
like less than 600 people,
you know,
once you get over like 600 people,
they're still fun.
There's still a lot of fun.
You know,
DC was more than 600 people I think,
but there's still,
it's still a good time.
Don't get me wrong,
but it's just not the same experience.
The same experience.
You get into comedy club,
it's like you're right there,
you're in the mix.
There's low ceilings and shit and it's
just 300 of you and your fucking around
just hanging out.
Okay.
Three tickets gets to try to get the
grant here.
Tell me $159 and sixty cents.
Three tickets.
A lot of money,
man.
Have I smoked weed with Doug Benson?
Probably don't remember though.
I must have a.
might not.
Although I think I did once.
I think I showed him the solo pipe was
going to get them on.
I think Doug's very nice guy.
Yeah,
he's a real cool guy.
Very nice guy.
And he did his podcast.
He's very fun to.
He's got a um,
I love movies,
podcasts,
but I was totally useless on it because
I'm not a big movie fan so they were
bunk and they were all going on,
especially patent patent as well was on
and he's a movie freak and they were
just quoting all these weird obscure
movies and weird and I just didn't know
anything.
I was useless.
They were like,
what's your favorite movie?
I'm like,
oh,
I don't have one favorite movie.
I don't think I have a favorite movie
man right now it's Avatar.
Just because I,
I never get fit.
I've never felt like that before.
You know,
I like in a movie like wow,
like that movie,
like even though it was dumb,
you know,
even though it was like Cliche,
it didn't matter.
It felt.
It felt so powerful,
you know?
It goes like moved to tears almost a
couple of times.
It's like me,
even though it was still,
it was like comic book style,
Super Powerful,
you know,
the images and the way it was done,
even though there was something,
some cliche shit in it doesn't matter.
Fucking awesome.
Did I get my Tomahawk Pipe?
Yes,
I did,
sir.
Actually there is right here,
but we haven't used it because it's kind
of weak.
It's very clogged already.
Yeah.
Well it's just,
it's a.
it's done.
It's done.
You're not really supposed to smoke with
supposed to me.
I've got to calm a hog.
Maybe it's a silly,
but yeah,
I got it.
Just so I could show you guys.
When did I start smoking weed?
I didn't start till I was like 30 years
old.
That's why I'm so passionate about it
because my whole life,
I thought that if you smoke weed you'd
be lazy.
You'd be a loser.
Because I knew a lot of dudes when I was
a kid and the guys that did drugs,
the guys that were partying all the
time,
they always want to fuck fucking their
lives up and I was terrified of fucking
my life up.
There was my number one fear was being a
loser.
My number one I didn't mind.
My ambition was all fucked up because it
wasn't that I wanted to be happy and I
wanted to,
you know,
find some place,
have some point of success and do you
know,
uh,
achieve some goal or you know,
be the something for a living that I
wanted to be.
I wasn't doing that.
I was just trying not to be a loser.
I was terrified I was going to be a
loser.
So,
um,
you know,
I think,
uh,
I think that's very important to have
the right mindset.
I,
you think like when you're growing up,
I'll try to answer that.
Yeah.
I think it's a lot with parents,
but also,
you know,
just how you were raised and the whole
package and how people,
how the people around you think too.
That's very important.
You know,
I don't even remember what I was talking
about,
how high we are.
There's a gentleman barbecued what we
were talking about,
something real simple.
We're talking about Avatar.
And by the way,
I find myself saw three d and I loved it
at fucking navy was so great.
Was the greatest movie ever to me.
I said I don't have a favorite movie,
but I guess if I had to have a favorite
movie,
any news on Brock Lesnar?
Um,
I heard randy couture.
So He's back in the gym.
That's awesome.
You know,
more important than anything even as
dude never fight again.
You know,
maybe he doesn't want to fight anymore.
Now you know,
the most important thing is that he's
healthy and the most important thing is
you ladies and gentlemen,
learn something from this situation,
eat your vegetables.
It's very important to each of fiber and
you got to clean out your intestinal
tract by juicer.
This motherfucker's been juicing,
juicing like crazy and it's been,
his whole life is like invigorated.
Right.
Gotcha,
Gotcha.
Oh,
it's been like five minutes after taking
one of these juices.
I feel like I could just go do jumping
jacks.
Why isn't this whack ass thing streaming
anymore?
I don't know,
man.
I just forward to support soccer.
Uh,
I use chrome now.
Oh,
this is,
this is firefox.
You know what?
I'm going to try to shut this.
I've been using chrome a lot lately.
I like criminal law.
I think it's the best so know better so
far.
He's the best I gave up on Firefox.
Firefox has been a worse lately.
Firefox has just been slow as fuck.
Really needs to be good.
Yeah.
Firefox crashes sometimes on me.
Shut up for Fox.
I got all my fancy new fucking bad ass
quick internet.
It shouldn't be on gate out.
A lot of people got really mad at me.
I did an interview recently and I talked
about,
uh,
the use of the word faggot.
I was just explaining how,
what happened when I did the spike TV
thing that they told him that I could
say any word except faggot when,
when the show was uncensored and I was
like,
this,
that's so crazy because I'm not even
talking to a person.
I'm talking to a dog and some aunts,
that's when I use the word faggot and it
has nothing to do with sexual
orientation,
you know?
And I know Louis C,
k a actually has a bit on that,
about how it never met gay.
And it didn't.
Anthony Cooney and talks about it all
the time on the opiod,
anthony,
about how fag it never really was a
homosexual slur when we were kids.
It was,
it was not.
I mean,
but that's true,
but it's so sort of not true because you
knew that it also meant that,
but people didn't use it that way.
That's not what it meant.
And at the end of the day,
like what's language is supposed to
represent is the context of your
thoughts,
you know,
and the problem is when words get hyper
powered,
like cunt or nigger or Faggot,
now faggot.
It's like the new one,
you know,
or love.
Love's a hyper powered word too.
You know,
these words get hyper powered and the
word itself is more important than the
meaning behind the word.
You're not.
It's not a true expression anymore.
Like I mean a lot of people in
relationships and you know,
he say you love me,
tell me you love me to love you.
It's like this weird fucking magic word
thing that you have to say.
It's like you should know by the way
someone communicates with you whether or
not they love you.
It shouldn't have to say this one word
shouldn't have all this goddamn power.
You know the same thing with the word
nigger and the same thing with the word
Faggot as a now I guess because this gay
guy told me when he was explaining this
to me that I couldn't say Faggot,
you know,
even if I didn't mean anything,
it didn't mean gay people.
I couldn't say it because I'm not gay.
He said,
but gay people could say [inaudible].
He goes,
it's our nigger.
Well,
of guys who is a kiss of John's
protests,
some duty met on the streets.
Wow,
that's shocking news.
TMZ.
Well,
it's great to be sued.
Who's Kissing A.
Obviously it's staged ladies and
gentlemen.
So this one's not staged for a where
he's getting into an airplane,
kissing another gentlemen.
Well,
you know,
maybe looks kissing gentleman doesn't
mean he's gay.
Brian,
I don't know where you're going with
this.
Listen,
just because John Travolta is kissing
mounties photos
and what did the audience said?
Dude was,
you want to say which,
and John Travolta is Gary than a room
full of Dicks in Vegas?
One of my favorite things here.
Well,
clearly I was
just saying it in jest,
Ladies Gentlemen.
I do not know who's homosexual.
There's a funny story that I've told
before,
but uh,
it's true story.
There was a dude who was a fighter in
this organization,
so other fighting organization outside
of the UFC and uh,
this was like the nineties and they want
to do a.
wasn't a google search even it was an
internet search on this man's name
because they were going to write a story
about him to promote his show.
And as they were searching him,
they found out that someone with the
same name was a gay porn star and not
just a gay porn star,
but the winner of the hungriest bud
contest,
not the runner up with the hungriest
spot contest fucking winter.
This dude one,
the hungriest but contest and they
didn't believe it was him.
And then they just started searching
more and they found photos and they
found photos of him.
Like one dudes in his mouth,
one dude on his ass,
and they're using them as like a Chinese
finger handcuffs and they found all this
porn on him.
Like the guy it was,
you know,
it was used pretty easy to find,
when the information first got on the
Internet,
porn was the first shit to get out
there.
Porn was there before anything else
before wikipedia,
before youtube,
porn was there.
So if you had porn on the Internet,
like you could basically get even stuff
that was illegal,
like the early traci lords videos,
you could have got those elite,
they could have got those back that you
can't get those now.
Like you'd go looking for a traci lords
video now,
anything that's illegal like that,
that shit is gone.
But back then you could get.
So gay porn,
it was all over the place.
This poor fuck.
They pulled up all these pictures and
videos and everything.
Nick in front of them.
And he was like bullshit.
But,
and then they showed him the photos and
you got all angry and he was the
headliner.
He was the big draw.
And uh,
he just explained that he looked,
he was down on his luck and it was a lot
of money.
There was a lot of money.
And so he did it.
Well.
It turns out he did like 100 movies.
And the joke is how much money is a lot
of money to you because if I think you
do one movie,
you live like you're in a Jay z video
for the rest of your life.
That's what you want to do.
Gay Sex on video.
What?
That's,
I got to see some Zeros.
I got to see a lot of commas and Zeros.
But this fucking guy did like a lot of
these.
And the joke was 115 videos.
By my accounts,
you should have all the money in the
world.
It should be no more money left for
anybody else unless you like it.
See if you like socking decks and if
you're gay then that's not bad at all.
There's no see this when people don't
understand like just because someone
thinks it's funny because they
personally are not,
they don't want to have gay sex.
That doesn't mean it's bad that you have
gay sex.
It's only bad for someone who doesn't
want to have the gay sex.
Right?
Brian?
Like if you're not gay and you do a gay
porn,
that's a big deal.
But if you're gaining do a gay porn,
it's like so up.
You're sucking dicks.
Is it any more embarrassing that you're
doing a video?
It's the same.
It's no different,
but if you're straight and you're out
there blogging guys on video.
Oh,
I stupid about it.
My Act that if a guy is like straight
and he's blown a guy,
you know that if you like made a mistake
one night and day like you'll never win
an argument ever for the rest of your
life because as soon as you get in the
argument,
as soon as shit starts getting real,
now you don't even believe people were
on the moon like didn't you start a dick
once and that's the end.
The arguments over.
There's no way you can bounce back from
that,
but what?
You got a dick in your mouth,
it's conversation's over.
You can't trust the judgment anymore.
You've,
you've defeated him.
You've deflated him as a human.
Do I feel very blessed to be as famous
as I am,
says genuine evil.
80 six.
That's hilarious.
Um,
yeah.
I'm just famous enough where it's not
creepy now I'm just famous enough where
no one takes me seriously.
First of all,
the fear factor was definitely a
blessing in disguise because,
you know what I'm saying?
Like,
you know,
you get to a place where like,
a lot of people are like real super
famous people that are like loved and
worshiped,
you know,
rock stars or Michael Jackson or
something like that,
or Tom Cruise or Brad Pitt,
like their prisoners.
Like they can't go anywhere.
Like that is a terrible way to live.
Like,
yeah,
everybody is fascinated by you,
including me.
If I saw Brad Pitt in a restaurant,
I was like,
point stare like me.
You want to hear something crazy?
Me and Kevin James.
Okay.
And Kevin James is fucking famous,
right?
That,
that Goddamn.
I'm Paul Blart Mall cop movie.
He did made like $200,
million dollars.
Okay.
And Kevin and I are in Boston and we're
in a hotel room and Tom Cruise was in
Boston too.
And Tom Cruise on the street.
Okay.
And Kevin's fucking hotel room.
And Kevin's like Tom Cruise is out
there.
Look.
And so leaning out the window looking at
Tom,
we're on
the 10th floor and Shit and Tom cruises
on the ground floor.
And we'll like looking at him across the
street like,
Woo,
I'm a movie star is Gawking at another
movie star.
It was pretty interesting to watch.
I was like,
you're,
I go do you know you're that famous.
Like he's not as famous as Tom Cruise,
but he's fucking really famous.
I mean it's silly that he's like so fat,
but that's what it is,
man.
People,
people are,
are,
are nutty about,
about fame.
That's not a good level.
You don't want to be there that you want
to be at the level where you don't have
to worry about your bills and you,
uh,
you know,
you're able to do what you want to do.
Like as far as creatively,
you know,
that's what I liked.
I liked the fact that I could do comedy,
I can do the UFC,
I do what I want to do and I'm enjoying
myself,
you know,
and it's fun and people enjoy what I'm
doing and you know,
you develop fans,
you develop people that are appreciating
what you do and you appreciate them and
it's a good relationship.
That's good level of fame.
You don't want to be,
you know,
you don't want to be somewhere like I
was.
I was watching some video online where
the guy.
Can you put that video up,
the dude when George Bush went to a
restaurant and he's with five secret
service agents and the guy is screaming
and yelling at him,
you fucking murder or Zionist murdering
piece of shit.
And some Guy George Bush senior has to.
The dude is like,
he's an old man.
He's been around forever.
He has to travel everywhere with these
bodyguards everywhere he goes.
He have secret service guys surrounding
him and yeah,
I know what you're saying.
Yeah,
no,
he caused wars and he's responsible for
all these people dying.
I see it 100 percent and it's not like
being a movie star,
but it's the same thing in as far as
like,
well,
no,
because people are angry at him.
Okay.
My point is terrible,
but it is right because people were
angry at him.
I mean he's the reason why he's got all
those people around because people want
him dead.
Everybody wants Brad Pitt dead is
fucking crazy.
But the point is,
any level of fame,
you know,
past a certain level can be.
It becomes a handicap.
It becomes like food.
If you have some food,
you should only eat until you're not
hungry anymore.
You shouldn't fucking gorgeous self and
go God damn crazy.
You know,
it's very difficult to manage any level
of fame and to manage the kind of fame
that those guys have managed.
I mean,
it's almost impossible.
That's why.
How,
why do you think Tom Cruise is so crazy?
You have to be crazy.
No one cannot be crazy if you're that
famous.
It's like impossible.
Like who can manage that kind of thing?
You know,
like when,
when he was on Matt Lauer talking about
psychiatrists and antidepressants,
like you're Glib,
your Glib,
like he doesn't even realize how
retarded he sounds.
No one tells him,
no one tells him that he's talking
nonsense.
He doesn't have a voice of reason around
him.
He doesn't have objectivity,
doesn't have anybody who talks to him
real.
He has people who gawk and stare and
look like Kevin James and I from the
10th floor of a hotel,
Tom Cruise.
No one's given that guy the real shit.
So when he gets on television and talks
with nonsense like he doesn't,
he has no idea what nonsense is.
He's crazy because he's super,
super famous and it's like almost
impossible to not be crazy.
We're all.
The rules are completely different for
you than they are for everybody else.
The rules for everybody else or most
people have to create an impression they
have.
You meet someone that you know,
you tell them,
you know what your name is,
what you're all about with him.
Everywhere he goes,
they know everything.
They know he's the same tologist.
They know he's the greatest fucking,
most successful movie star in the
history of the world.
I mean,
that fucking guy can't go anywhere.
Everybody wants to say he's like five
foot one and oh,
he's gay and he's fucking crazy and
everybody's staring and scrutinize them.
You know that marriage that he had,
that first one,
that called and that was all set up and
I was on a real.
Everybody's constantly up in a shit.
How could you not be crazy?
Right?
Yeah.
Brian gets a.
He gets a lot of internet fame.
You got a lot of Weirdos.
They get upset at you.
You got a lot of weird.
How about that Pepsi Spice thing?
Listen,
listen,
this story,
this,
this dude,
when Pepsi guys remember when Pepsi
Spice was around,
well Brian is like one of the Internet
gangsters.
He was like,
he was aware of Shit.
The companies weren't aware of.
You know,
companies were like these multi,
multi billion dollar companies,
but there really weren't deep in the
Internet.
They didn't understand the impact it
had.
So when Pepsi Spice came out,
they didn't have Pepsi Spice Dot Com.
So Brian Bought Pepsi slice on and Brian
started putting up all these crazy
because it's still up.
Or did you get sued?
Uh,
the website?
Yeah,
I let it go because I was tired of
paying for it and they weren't bringing
back the.
Did you give it to them?
Uh,
no.
I just let it go.
Somebody picked somebody else pick it
up.
But what did you do with all those,
those crazy stories that you wrote on
it?
I will tell everybody about the stores
pretty much.
I just copied off that Morgan spurlock
guy and I,
I said that I was going to drink pepsi,
Pepsi holiday spice for 30 days.
What are the people that don't know?
That's from supersize me and ate
Mcdonald's for 30 days.
It's a documentary.
Pretty good one.
Yeah.
And so,
so,
uh,
I had,
I could only have pepsi spice to eat and
drink for 30 days,
which is alone.
The dumbest thing in the world that
anyone believed it,
you know,
like I'm not going to eat food.
I'm going to,
you know,
have.
So that started having like the first
couple of days they started having these
lesions and stuff like,
can you photoshop these things on fake
things?
I made myself look more and more sick.
I was losing weight and I was telling
him like my photoshopping fat off me and
what's crazy is then I started getting
interviews from radio stations thinking
it's real and I have it somewhere like
this two hour interview where a college
radio station.
It was real.
And uh,
I had people actually I started really
thinking I was like dying and stuff like
that.
And then one day I stopped like 20 days
in and people all thought I died.
It was one of the great trolls.
One of the all time.
Great trolls.
Yeah,
it was really brilliant.
Yeah.
Just look up Pepsi spice projects,
but something's gone.
Goddamn brilliant.
Trolls on the Internet,
you know,
the best is Doug Stan hope on Baiting,
baiting.org.
Doug Stan hope would go and bait
pedophiles and then right,
like I think they did a about it.
Then they do a book,
they put it in a book form of thing.
Yeah,
I think so.
I believe it's still available on,
if you go to Doug Stan hope.com,
you'll probably have a link to it
somewhere because one of those,
one of the funniest things that doug
ever did and he would pretend to be a
little girl and Laura pedophiles and say
like all kinds of fucked up shit and it
was really,
really genius stuff.
I,
I don't,
I can't pull any of the quotes off the
top of my head,
but I remember really laughing really
hard and wanting to do the same thing,
but I don't have
that kind of commitment.
Doug is.
Doug is an animal.
He's a pit bull.
The level of commitment that he has
towards trolling.
I don't know.
I'm not into like goofing on.
People don't know why like that.
Like I,
I get bored.
I mean I,
I'll argue with people and I'll make fun
of someone but like pretending to be
someone else going back and forth for
whatever reason.
My brain doesn't work that way,
you know?
I don't know why I don't get into those
trolls,
but I love watching them like that.
Pepsi Spice One.
I love that one.
That was awesome.
And Doug's.
I loved them.
I just don't.
I don't.
My brain doesn't think like that.
Here's that.
Here's when I actually.
This is when the first video site did
special effects on.
Here's the,
here's the video from Pepsi spice where
it's like one of the first times I did
like a real good special bad assets as
video and video shit.
This is dope folks.
Just like we've got a real God damn show
here.
People can you see it by the way,
all the Shit I do.
This is probably one of the funniest
things I do.
This is fun.
You know,
we look forward to this.
Who's that?
Good job pushing up.
It's me.
I'm fucking myself.
Pepsi spreads.
Oh,
this is my spice.
That guy that people would think.
Chicken Pepsi's.
That's hilarious.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Dude.
That's very fine.
Have I seen Jessie Ventura's nurse new
show?
No,
I have not.
I'm not seeing Jesse Ventura's new show.
I don't know shit about Jesse Ventura's
new show.
I know it's some sort of a crazy
conspiracy theory.
Sounds awesome.
I like conspiracy theories up to a
point.
My God,
dude,
Brian's going to pay.
You guys want to see his Dick?
Can you talk about the music you like?
You should listen to phish dead
wires.
Call what the fuck?
My toilet.
How do you even know?
What is your name?
P Q I l e s 24.
This is the dude who likes the dead and
the fish.
Okay,
man,
I don't get the dead or the fish.
I don't get it.
I understand that you like it and I
would never say that it's not good
because it's obviously good to you.
You know,
I gave up saying some things suck a long
time ago when people like them because
it occurred to me somewhere along the
line that they,
even though they suck for me,
even though I do think they suck as long
as you know,
what do I care?
As long as it's not promoting anything
ridiculously stupid.
Well,
as long as it's not,
you know,
reinforcing retarded behavior as long as
it's not negative for human beings.
What do I give a shit?
You know,
you think it's good.
You like it?
I can't get into it,
man.
I can't listen to the debt on that.
I tried,
I did this grateful dead experiment
where,
uh,
I tried to listen to it for 30 days,
but I was hating it so much that I
didn't want to run.
I was going to write about it.
I was going to read,
I was going to listen to dad for 30 days
and then write about it at the end.
It's just not my shit,
but that's okay.
You know what I mean?
You can like it.
But like I was listening to the dead one
day and uh,
I put on right after I listened to it.
I was listening to for like an hour and
then I put on midnight rider by the
allman brothers and I never listened to
the debt again.
I was like,
are you fucking kidding me man?
Are you fucking kidding me?
I mean,
look,
I know some people like the grateful
dead and I understand and I appreciate
it and shit like that,
but,
but listen,
man,
there's some fucking music that there's,
there's some music this on another level
and in my opinion,
the shit from looking for this.
Why am I making sense here?
I'm looking for the song.
Shut the fuck up.
Um,
I spoke to her damn own brothers,
you know,
this is a whack ass setup.
What is the basic building makes
himself.
You can't,
you're going to get arrested.
Huh?
You're going to get a right.
You could do this.
You,
yeah.
This is a picture of a picture.
Oh really?
Yeah.
You allowed to do that?
Well,
I mean,
so that's the UFC.
They'll see the.
I can't find the allman brothers.
Here we go.
Okay.
Shut that off for a second.
Listen to this shit.
Listen to machine.
Oh,
that's rambling man.
That's not what it was.
It was midnight rider fucking con.
Do I not have that?
How is that possible?
I get it out of my fucking phone.
How do I not have it on my itunes?
Oh,
there it is.
You Bitch.
Okay,
here we go.
What the Hell is gonna?
Meet your screen.
You're going to hear this immediately.
You have to meet your screen.
Oh,
otherwise it won't play,
right?
Is that what it is?
Well,
you're just gonna Echo yourself.
Okay.
Yeah.
Alright,
here we go.
You know you can listen to the grateful
dead all day.
That's all good.
This plane did terrible.
Let me know.
I listen to that.
Ah Man,
I can't go back.
I can't go back to the grateful dead.
I can't do it.
I understand it.
If you like it,
it's not my shit.
I like some rap music.
I like seventies music.
The midnight ride from the allman
brothers.
I don't know if it sounded good to you
guys.
It sounded awesome.
So great.
God Damn fucking song.
Just to some of the shit they did in the
seventies,
man and stuff just so resonates today,
man.
You know,
you listen to some,
some of the sixties and seventies music
Zeplin the doors and just there's
something about it man,
that like when I'm like in a mood,
don't want to hear something.
Especially if you smoke a joint and you
know,
you sit in front of a computer,
you want to write,
I'll put on some fucking classic rock
man.
It just,
it makes you,
it just makes you feel more connected.
It's just like there's something about
that music,
like whatever they were doing at the
time and they were making that music.
They were nailing it.
They,
it,
you know,
there's music from that era that doesn't
smell at all,
like commercial.
It doesn't smell at all.
Like,
like they were trying to,
you know,
to trick people or do something,
thought it was going to be successful.
There's a bunch of music from that era
that's just beautiful man.
It's just a lie.
It's like the pure,
the purest version of,
of musical art.
You know,
and I think it's because they were all
doing psychedelic drugs.
I mean,
I think there are a lot to do with it.
Everybody was high,
everybody was smoking pot.
They were dropping acid and taking
mushrooms and they were coming out with
dope fucking music man.
And today,
still to this day,
I mean no one's going to be listening to
pop,
pop poker face.
No one's going to listen to that in 30
years.
No one's going to listen.
That 40 years led Zepplin will be around
in 40 years.
Forty years from now,
some fucking dude in a spaceship is
going to turn some other dude in a
spaceship onto whole lot of love.
Probably not 40 years.
We'll still be stuck on this planet for
100 years from now.
That shouldn't be like Mozart.
No one's going to remember pop up poker
face.
I,
you remember that right?
Why don't you agree?
I know it's pretty big song.
I think you've just hating on the APP.
You liked that song.
I think it was okay at the beginning,
but I mean the main thing that,
who cares about me?
That's like my number,
a number one song,
you know,
not every song is number one.
You know?
Um,
what about what people remember it?
I don't know.
I think that sounds horrible.
Does anybody here?
I mean,
Lady Gaga,
she's not bad.
She.
Yeah.
This dude is down,
man.
Kevin Newcomb knows what the fuck I'm
talking about.
This is there.
The best music,
the allman brothers.
Just soulful man.
There's something about those.
When Joey Diaz describes it as the best,
those dirty motherfucking white boys.
Dirty white boys from Florida.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Getting that pure heroin able.
They will play in the real music.
Joe Rogan.
You gotta get your ideas on ideas will
be here next week.
We're going to drag them in here next
week even if we have to change the
schedule for the show and do it at a
different time right now because I
didn't look at this at all the last time
we did this.
I have to look at it now.
Yeah.
I made a post on my message board asking
people to put in questions.
So uh,
because of that I'm going to go there
right now and check it out what the
questions are and see if anybody has
some cool shit because people were upset
that I did it last week.
But when I did it last week I didn't
answer any questions.
But I mean,
I like the questions and I,
it's good to have the questions,
but I wanted to make this as loose as
possible.
I want to make this as much as whatever
we feel are talking about,
you know,
whatever,
whoever's here,
just let things come out,
you know,
and answer twitter questions and all
that shit.
What are the best tips for navigating a
high dose mushroom trip?
Are you doing them regularly?
I was the first question.
I don't do them regularly.
I'm Terence Mckenna,
who I learned everything I know about
psychedelics from that guy,
or at least that's where I started
listening to what he had to say,
reading his books.
But what he always said is that you
should do them in a high doses.
And very rarely,
that's what he said.
He said that psychedelic experiences
shouldn't be something where you do the
right dose and then you take a long time
off and try to sort of contemplate what
happened.
And uh,
I agree with that.
The last time I did anything really
strong like DMT,
there was over two years ago and it was
because it was a very,
very,
very profound experience and I wanted to
make sure that I got as much out of it
and they understood it and sort of
deciphered it as much as I could and
applied it to my life as as I could
before I just went to try to do it
again.
I'm,
I'm very serious about psychedelic
trips.
I don't think it's play.
I mean I think you can have a good time
of mushrooms with your buddies if you
don't take too much,
but I think you can get a lot out of
psychedelic trips where you.
And I'm not criticizing people want to
do it for fun because look,
I like to drink for fun.
Smoke pot for funds.
I smoked pot both for introspective
quality thinking and also for fun and I
don't if you want to do it for fun,
that's all good.
But what I'm saying is like,
for me personally,
I've learned a lot from psychedelic
experiences,
and what I believe is what turns Mckenna
has always said is that you should do
them very rarely.
You do,
um,
and then you don't do shit for a while
and you think about what the fuck you
learned because it doesn't.
If you really want to prove yourself,
you really using it for that reason to
really expand your consciousness.
You don't get anything out of it.
If you can't apply it to your life,
you can't just have the experience and
then becomes some fucking shut in who
doesn't interact with the rest of the
world.
Because all you want to do is go down in
your basement,
turn the lights out,
and do mushrooms,
a curiosity.
Now you're not even a part of us
anymore.
Like you should be able to.
You've got to be able to function in
both worlds,
in the psychedelic world and in this
world.
You got to be able to navigate both
dimensions.
And I think if you do too much drugs,
if you do them all the time,
you know,
you can,
you can definitely lose your handle on
this world.
So that's my answer to that question.
I think if you're,
if you're doing anything consciousness
expanding,
you know,
and always do things that have been done
for thousands and thousands of years.
I mean,
I'm not telling you to do anything
illegal,
but there's stuff that you can do that
isn't illegal.
They just haven't classified it yet.
You know,
Iowasca isn't technically illegal.
DMT is illegal.
IOWASCA has even been sanctioned
recently.
Uh,
they,
uh,
some church in New Mexico won a supreme
court case where they,
uh,
they take dmt as part of their,
their Christian church.
It's part of their religious ceremonies
to get in touch with God.
Yeah,
they want a supreme court case for few
people know about it.
But you should know what the fuck you're
doing.
And that's the real problem with
psychedelics is that there are no shaman
anymore.
You know,
in the,
in,
you know,
these tribes in Peru and these people
that live in the Amazon there,
there's like a history of usage that
goes back thousands of years and they
pass it on from generation to
generation.
And the Shaman,
the people that like brew this Iowasca
Iowasca is very powerful dose of,
uh,
of dmt that comes in an orally active
form and they get it from combining
these plants and boiling and into this
crazy mixture between that.
And there's also shaman and other parts
of the world in Mexico where they,
um,
they,
they're Sharman where they,
their thing is mushrooms.
And these are people that have navigated
these dimensions,
whether it's Iowaska or mushrooms or
pod.
They've navigated these dimensions many,
many,
many times.
So they can tell you what to expect
there.
They can,
they've,
they've learned from their experiences
and they can help you.
You know,
I think that's the real problem is that
psychedelic drugs aren't necessarily bad
for you.
They're just illegal.
And when they're illegal can be bad for
you because if you need car with them
and get locked up,
your life can get fucked up if they find
them on your in your purse,
if you have to test for some sort of a
job and then all of a sudden you're
labeled a drug addict.
Yeah.
And that sense psychedelic drugs can be
bad.
And the other sense it's like a circular
saw like one those,
those are awesome.
If you know how to use one,
you can build a house,
you could,
you could fucking do some cool shit.
You can cut some wood that you would
never be able to cut with like a steak
knife.
But it doesn't mean everybody should
have a fucking circular saw and just be
using it all day.
And that's the same thing with
mushrooms.
Mushrooms are just like any kind of tool
you can like.
Like I said,
with marijuana,
with a hammer,
you can build a house with a hammer or
you can just hit yourself in the deck if
you're fucking crazy.
It doesn't mean that hammer should be
illegal.
And that's the same thing with
psychedelic drugs.
I wouldn't give a circular saw to a 13
year old boy and say,
Hey,
go play with this.
But if a guy is a goddamn carpenter and
he knows what he's doing and he's Kinda
gone up through trade school and you
know,
it didn't apprenticeship and worked as a
carpenter's apprentice and learned how
to use tools properly and learn the
proper safety precautions,
then yeah,
that guy should be able to hold a
fucking chainsaw.
That guy should be able to use a
circular saw.
That guy should be able to work in a
machine shop.
He's learned how to do it.
And that's the same thing with
psychedelic drugs.
There should be someone showing you the
dangers and the pitfalls and what it's
all about because it's not simply that
easy.
It's not like you can just do them and
you're going to be okay.
Some people do psychedelic drugs and
there's so unmentally prepared for it,
but they're never the same again.
You know?
And that's a real possibility and
someone needs to be there to evaluate
whether or not,
you know,
you've got the proper information with
your head's in the right place,
you know,
and that,
that's why it would help if we were more
open about these fucking things.
And it's the nutty thing is it's,
it's still got this terrible reputation
and here we are,
you know,
in 2010.
And I think the reputation is all based
on the fact that we,
when we get something in our head,
we stick with it and we get something in
our head.
Even with all the information,
like marijuana is still illegal,
2010 and most states it's illegal,
you know,
it's crazy when alcohol and tobacco and
all that shit is readily available.
But we get it in our head that it's bad
because it's been illegal.
All our lives were.
It's a very tough for us to change
gears.
And for a long time we've had this thing
in our head about psychedelic drugs.
And uh,
it's just a cultural pattern,
you know,
it's just a lock.
We got talked into it when the media was
young and when the newspapers were
around and that was the only way to get
information.
Now they would publish these stories
about marijuana and the William Randolph
hearst scandals with William Randolph
hearst owned not only deedee own
newspapers,
but he also owned paper mills and when
they invented the decorticator,
it made it more effective to process
hemp fiber and what he started doing was
attacking the hemp industry so that he
didn't have to change over his paper
mills from wood to hemp paper,
because hemp is a far superior paper.
It makes superior clothing.
It's you.
You can eat it like the is.
It contains all the essential amino
acids and the seeds besides the fact
that it gets you high,
even take away.
That gets you high part.
Even the plants that don't get you high
at all or still like really economically
viable,
valuable.
Well we'll we'll you ran off first
attack that industry because you own the
newspapers.
He started printing these stories saying
that blacks and Mexicans were swept
smoking this new drug called marijuana
and they were going out and raping white
women.
And so because of that,
because he did this,
they all,
um,
you know,
people got crazy and they'll pat got
paranoid and congress actually outlawed
marijuana not even knowing that they
were outlawing hemp.
They didn't even know it was the same
thing.
So that's,
that's how marijuana became illegal in
the first place.
And that's why it's still illegal today
is at once something is stuck in our
consciousness.
It takes a long time to get it out.
Well,
I think that a long time ago,
a long time ago,
it was probably very,
very common in all cultures to have a
shaman,
to have some sort of a,
you know,
someone who is aware of psychedelic
states,
you know,
John,
Marco Allegro,
uh,
he argues that that's what Christianity
is all about.
Christianity is all about concealing
these secrets of consuming
hallucinogenic drugs.
He was the guy who decided for the Dead
Sea Scrolls.
John Mark or allegro,
worked in the Dead Sea Scrolls for 14
years.
And after he did all this discovery,
now I don't know if he's right and
neither of you,
unless you're a biblical scholar,
unless you can,
you know,
you have to be a,
a master of ancient languages.
You have to study it for decades.
Even understand what the fuck he's
talking about.
I read it,
it's like make sense sort of,
but it could be totally bullshitting.
But what his story is was that the
entire Christian religion was a giant
misunderstanding.
What it really was all about was the
consumption of psychedelic mushrooms and
fertility cults.
And that's what it was all about.
It was all about breeding babies and
taking mushrooms,
which makes sense.
People live thousands and thousands of
years ago and didn't know what the sky
was.
They didn't have any science and they're
popping mushrooms.
They would.
They wouldn't want other people to know
how bad ass the mushrooms are.
You eat mushrooms,
you see God.
It wouldn't want other people to know
about that.
So they would hide it in stories.
I told them make sense?
Some guy said,
I've been tried robitussin.
What are you kidding?
Do Caucus Powell drinking robitussin?
What else?
Dragon Aftershave,
Phil agreed,
discusses,
hates everything in the radio.
I don't hate everything on the radio,
but Goddamn,
I had a lot of songs.
I think there's just a certain reality
and it was like a lot of rap and a lot
of classic rock.
I like soundgarden too.
I love sound garden.
I heard they're getting back together
again,
which I love because I was not a fan of
that.
Chris Cornell Shit I was on.
Yeah.
Lately I haven't been a fan.
He seems like a really cool guy and he's
a talented as fuck as a singer,
but there's like some bands that get
together.
They got to a magic,
you know?
I don't think it.
Even if they get back together,
I don't think it's going to be that
character willing.
Yeah,
I think.
I think a lot of bands like soundgarden,
they were good because they were a young
and every eight doing drugs and going
crazy and just experiencing life now.
I think these are just people that have
slowed down,
slowed their role and they're trying to
be something or because their music.
Just a lot of these guys as music or I
think that was kind of what I was
talking about earlier when I was saying
that there's a certain level that you
reach as a,
I'm a performer,
you know,
if you get too famous,
you get too successful.
It's very hard to,
to,
to cope.
Very hard to be still creative and still
have enthusiasm.
I mean,
how many guys just get better and better
every album.
It's not that many know stereo.
Hard to pull off.
Who Do you think has ever done it the
longest?
Most consistently.
Wells that blend.
One of those guys,
probably the Beatles did it forever.
Right?
Did they ever fall apart?
They got better,
right?
Yeah,
they did.
They got into their psychedelic stage,
you know,
they're fucking white album stage,
better beatles rock band.
It's great because he started off like
Shitty Beatles songs and you're just
like,
this sucks or whatever,
and then you start getting into like
psychedelic and it's just,
it's cool.
The more you play the more into the
music scene.
The thing about the Beatles was they
didn't just change their music.
They changed the whole culture that was
listening to them too because people got
swept up in their music.
People were such huge fans of John
Lennon and when he started getting into
transcendental meditation and acid and
you know,
hanging out with gurus and shit,
they hold onto it too.
Like he changed a lot of people's
consciousness.
That was a guy that really,
really affected a lot of the way our
culture operates,
the way people think about Michael
Jackson to fuck you.
Yeah.
Michael Jackson.
Just from the,
the,
the music,
like how powerful it was like bad and
thriller,
man when I was a kid,
there was nothing that was more popular
than that.
It's like it was so recognized that his
talent was just so far and above
everyone else's.
And you know,
everybody's like,
God.
It's so sad that he's such a freak and
he's so crazy.
But the more I've been thinking lately,
I think that when you get to a certain
level,
I think there's a certain level of,
um,
of greatness that some people achieve
like a certain frequency that some
people cheap and it's almost impossible
to achieve.
If you're not insane,
it's almost impossible to push yourself
that far that hard because it's not easy
to be like Michael Jackson.
It's so fucking hard.
It's not just natural talent.
It's a focus and an energy and that
focus requires like a very singular way
of looking at things in a very essential
question by sexual abuse and that
probably helps to relax in the back of
his.
What do you think that's what happened
with him?
You think it was when I was a kid,
I think probably.
I mean,
well,
it's all speculation.
They all were.
He could have been that.
He just got so fucked up because he got
so famous when he was so young that he
never felt like he had a chance to grow
up and he wanted to go back to when he
was a child and it was just so
psychologically damaged that he
literally wanted to be around children
because he wanted to revert back to that
moment in his life before he realized
that life was haywire.
You know?
I've thought that before because you
know what the thing is about all these
child molesting accusations is that he
was always around all these poor kids
and trying to help all these kids with
cancer and shit and people were who were
broke and it's like after awhile,
I mean these people,
like all they have to do is say some
crazy shit about Michael Jackson and you
know,
it looks weird.
Why is my Jackson hanging out with kids
all the time?
I would say some crazy shit and he's
gotta pay you gotta pay.
You start going through the newspaper
and to these people that were super
broke.
I mean,
that'd be so tempting.
Here's this billionaire,
the biggest rockstar music star and the
history of the world and he's hanging
out with your kid.
He's a kid.
Your kid over for sleepovers and you
start.
I believe it though in some I've paid
him
the.
What I'm saying is there's not like a
whole bunch of people coming out saying
he fucked up.
You want to just fuck a couple of kids.
You'd be fucking kids all over the
place.
Especially if you're Michael Jackson.
You'd be like the tiger woods of kid
fucking.
You'd be just banging kids all over the
place.
You would if you got that obsession
where you want to have sex with kids.
If you look at like trauma masters,
like the recidivism rate is through the
roof.
It's crazy.
It's like a 99 percent or something like
that.
I don't know.
It's real.
I just made that number up.
It's real high though.
Whatever it is.
I've read it.
I don't remember what the numbers are,
but the people have said time and time
again,
it's very difficult to reform someone,
so if he's like banging kids,
he's not just going to bang one or two,
but that's why he had kids and he called
the kid blanket because he's always on
top of him.
That's bullshit.
Seriously though.
I mean if you're a child molester and
you get caught,
what don't you have kids?
You're just get enough money.
Yeah,
but
no,
none of his kids have ever come out and
accused him of doing that.
You can't just say that you're just,
you're adding on now you're making.
I'm not saying it's true.
I'm just saying,
but I'm going to say that's what I
believe in.
I don't believe me.
I believe that he probably slept with
kids,
but I don't think he's like,
fuck,
you know,
like doggy style on the side of the bed
or anything like that.
So you think he just did inappropriate
shit?
I bet he's just because he thinks he's a
kid.
You know?
Maybe I was molested by his father
growing up.
That would cause.
I mean Miley Cyrus would be fucking
black by now if that was true.
Yeah.
Somebody said this.
I don't know who said this,
but I don't want to not give them
credit,
but I don't remember who it was.
They said that they think that Michael
Jackson might've been castrated.
They think that at certain point in time
Michael Jackson might've been castrated
and that's why he can sing at such a
high pitch,
even though he's a grown man.
That might be why so fucked up sexually
and it totally makes sense.
Especially when you look at his
children.
Those are not his children.
I mean,
there were white kids there,
100 percent white and he's a black man.
I mean he might've paid for someone to
have those kids for them,
but they're not as kids,
you know,
and I think that it's real possible
that,
that that's real possible,
but it's special
culation Janet and all them,
all kinds of hair,
that kind of voice.
You know,
Tito doesn't.
Jermaine doesn't.
Those are men.
You look at his brother,
those are men.
Unless he's like some sort of a,
a biological freak.
Why does he have that voice?
Why is he looked like that?
Why is he so feminine?
Why is his voice so high pitched?
Even though he's a grown man?
I mean,
could you imagine would if.
What if?
I mean he's so crazy with his fucking
plastic surgery.
What if he had some bad sexual
experiences when he was younger and he
just decided to Castro himself?
I mean,
you look at what he does to his face.
That's not beyond the realm of question.
I'm just making a fucking rumors.
Two hours and five minutes and this to
the goddamn rumors show.
Folks,
what does that,
this is my anger to one of these twitter
posters.
I love those guys.
I just to get math,
there's like those guys that just trying
to get your tag.
Look at me,
look at me like every five posts.
It's the same guy.
Australian men can't get hard,
man.
Oh,
can get hard man.
Uh,
they can trust me.
I know.
It's funny.
I thought that was the whole point.
Castrating people,
unless you take like you have to take
Viagra or some.
How do you,
how do you.
Does anybody know this?
Are there any dick experts out there on
the twitter?
Ladies and gentlemen,
please give me some information.
Can you really get a hard on after
Castro did?
Not by natural means,
right?
You have to take something.
It seems like when the balls are whacked
out,
that's a rap song.
That's a rug son.
So wrap,
son.
I'm glad you guys are enjoying the JPG
for ps zero.
This is fun.
It's fun for me too,
man.
What?
I banged a 16 year old.
No Man.
Listen,
you know they look hot.
That's a problem.
And they're ready to fuck.
They really are,
you know,
teenagers.
I mean,
I'm not saying anybody should fuck them,
but when you see a girl,
like when I was 16,
when I was 16,
I was having sex weren't you?
I was having sex and my girlfriend was
15 and she was built like a woman to a
woman.
She had Turks and she had a big ass and
it was a woman and she wanted sex all
the time.
I mean,
that's a,
that shit is real.
You know what I mean?
That's,
but you're not supposed to deal it.
Doug Stanhope as a joke about it.
Me and uh,
Brian,
uh,
me and a are ever talking about it on
the plane already told me the joke that
Doug said,
and apparently Doug said,
you know,
you say that data that they're 16 years
old,
they shouldn't be having babies.
Well guess what?
God disagrees.
That's why they can get pregnant.
And that's a really good point.
You know,
I mean,
that's really true.
But no,
I wouldn't have sex with a 16 year old.
That's a child,
you know.
I mean,
even if a girl is like 20,
like I'm 40 fucking two years old,
like I've heard of dudes that are like
my age that have like 20 year old
girlfriends and everybody laughs about
it.
Like,
well look at that guy he's got,
have a buddy that has a wife and his
wife's 19,
you know,
and he's in his forties.
It's crazy.
But you know what?
That's them.
The,
they,
they like it and they have a good time
to.
I have a hard time talking to people,
you know,
I can't.
I mean if I'm living with someone they
have to be smart.
I'm,
I need someone who has some experience.
You have to be on the same level as me.
And there's something that you denied
when you're younger but you realize when
you get older is that when you fuck,
when you have sex with someone,
even though you like to think that it's
just physical,
you just getting there and you blow a
lobe.
It's not that simple.
There is some sort of a weird connection
that human beings make when they fuck.
And especially when you do it to someone
who's young,
like they,
we learn how to ignore that connection
and we learned how to like push each
other away when a little older we
learned how to separate and get,
you know,
just deal with it about physically.
But when you're young,
like you get so attached,
you remember how attached to her the
first person you had sex with,
Holy Shit.
Unless that person's a total douche bag,
you know,
like you,
like it really like hooked on them.
Like puppy love is brutal,
you know,
and that that's what they call a.
you're inexperienced in the incredible
connection and you as you get older,
you learn how to manage that connection.
But the connection is real.
And if you're a grown adult and you
know,
you're,
especially if you're in a position to
take advantage of this kid,
you know,
they're young and naive and silly and
you're fucking them.
That's a weird thing,
you know.
Then again,
a lot of 20 year olds are Horny as fuck
or they want them to.
I'm not telling you what to do,
do whatever you want to do.
But to me not,
you know,
girls 18,
that's like a baby to me,
it's as a little child.
I like women,
you know,
I don't like.
I'm old.
I don't even like a my urge,
but it's women are more fun.
I like to be able to talk to people.
Don't you?
Some dude,
Josh Jitsu says I'm 23.
Well,
good for you.
You young little whipper snapper.
When I was 23,
I was fucking retarded,
right?
I was a complete and total dumb ass.
So I hope you were smarter than me sir.
Because a life can be tough when you're
stupid,
you know?
And if we all come from a different
place,
you know,
when I'll have a different,
um,
a different starting point,
that's what it is.
You know,
some people,
their parents are super cool and real
open and their dads,
their best friend and you know,
and their dad was,
you know,
very educated and intelligent and raise
them,
you know,
very,
very smart way.
And that person has a huge headstart.
Huge,
huge,
huge headstart in life.
If your parents are cool.
My parents were divorced when I was a
little kid.
My,
you know,
my Stepdad came into the picture when I
was seven.
He was 24.
And imagine if you were 24 years old and
you know,
actually I was five when he came into
picture.
You were 24 years old and you have a
fucking five year old kid hanging around
with you,
you know.
So if he came in the picture when I was
five,
then he was like 22,
that's young as fuck,
you know,
to be that young and to be around
someone else's kid,
someone else's loud ass kid,
you know,
that's hard to deal with.
So a lot of you out there and maybe you
my 23 year old friend,
maybe you have a headstart,
you know,
maybe you'll be smarter than me when you
were 23 than when I was 23.
But I think um,
what,
what I was talking about recently with a
friend of mine was that guys like
Michael Jackson or you know,
or,
or anybody that I know that's
exceptional.
Almost everybody I know that's really
exceptional at anything had kind of a
fucked up childhood.
I think that's really weird.
You know,
people that I know that are like all my
friends that are really good comics,
all my friends that are like really good
artists.
All of them had fucked up childhoods we
doing.
Showing the beginning thing again,
showing the beginning thing again.
That'd be getting things pretty bad ass.
I think um,
you know,
I think it's horrible.
You know,
that people have fucked up childhoods.
But I think there's something,
something that comes out of that.
Right.
You know,
like when you're in balanced,
it's like your,
your ride is so much rockier,
but there's so much more energy behind
it.
It's like if you can get ahold of it
and,
and control your personality and,
and figuring out a way to stabilize it
and it's like you have so much more
thrust than a person who is content,
but it might be unhealthy.
Final words,
final words.
Listen,
pitches sign,
kind of final words will tell you a
couple of these questions in the forums
dot Joe Rogan.net
website.
Before we bail,
this is fucking question.
What is your take on the Global Freeman
on the land movement?
What do you think?
Without law and order,
people generally maintain the peace or
descend into anarchy.
That's hilarious.
Some people are just waiting for shit to
fall apart,
man.
You know?
How many people do we have on our
message board?
This is a dude named 42 kang.
Just listen to the first question.
What is your take on the Global Freeman
on the land movement?
Fuck,
are you talking about man?
What does that mean?
What does.
What do you.
What are you saying?
What's your take?
This is my favorite thing.
When people go,
man,
you're gonna have to.
Gold is going to be come with valuable.
Our going gonna fall apart,
man.
It's going to be only thing that's going
to be worth something is gold.
Really?
Did you ever watch Mad Max?
You stupid.
Fuck.
When society falls apart,
you're gonna.
Need a car and guns and gasoline.
Okay.
You're not going to need gold.
Nobody gives a fuck about that stupid
yellow metal.
You're going to need bullets.
Okay?
Yummy food and a place to sleep.
It's warm.
You know what I'm saying?
The fuck are you dealing with gold.
Gold isn't worth anything.
Pussy and guns.
That's.
That's all.
Those are valuable assets.
Cars.
That's important.
House as important.
Preferably surrounded by chain link,
fence and dogs.
Okay.
That's what you're going to need.
You're not going to go you dumb.
Fuck.
What do I think about James?
Tony fight in the UFC.
I'm a huge James Tony Fan.
He was an awesome boxer.
Still isn't awesome boxer,
but you know,
I don't know if he's really into it.
If he's really into it.
He said,
fucking,
you know,
fucking champion a guy.
So good at boxing and wrestling.
If you're really.
Who knows?
Maybe he's been.
He's been watching this shit for years.
We don't know.
Everybody's talking shit.
He might've been secretly working on his
wrestling.
He might have a six bra.
If you've got to
stand up with that dude and he's got
four ounce gloves.
He's gonna fuck you up.
Oh Damn.
James.
Tony boxing with you.
That guy is going to fuck you up.
I don't know how he eats those leg
kicks.
Leg Kicks.
Fuck them up.
Get a guy like ray cifo in there with
them.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
Those fucking thunderous tree trunk leg
kicks down on your meat and making your
legs buckle.
You only took a couple of those bitches
and page through yet.
No.
Well,
I have everything set up.
So there's 100 images at or 100 posts.
Why my site excited about coming to
Toronto?
Have I ever been?
No,
I've never been in Toronto and I can't
fucking wait.
Your wife has nice tits.
Maltipoo very nice tits.
Aaron told me to say that.
He said Tell my wife she has nice tits.
She does.
She has nice tits.
Congratulations sir.
I'm reading the page,
man.
You're not seeing.
He said,
I'm just seeing if he's reading the
page.
Really?
You had to say that because you didn't
want to be bragging about your wife's
tits.
You know what to say about being drugs,
but smoking weed and fucking is just
awesome.
Being drunk is better when it comes to
eating pussy though.
Really?
Being not in my opinion,
in my opinion,
being drunk is better when it comes to
eating ass because it's the only time I
do it because I never even asked when
I'm sober.
The only time he had asked me sober is
when you just get out of jail.
So when you're.
When you're high,
you don't want to eat ass either,
but I beat the fuck out of some pussy
rental heart.
You just,
you like it depends.
It's Megan Fox asked.
I'll eat that anytime of day.
Anytime of the day he thought ass talk,
Yak.
What if it's all poor?
Don't care.
Either wipe it off and just dive in
there.
I'll wipe it off with your mouth.
I'll start with the hair.
Well,
that's why I think it's important to
drink drinking.
The reason why drinking and eating ass
goes in hand in hand is the alcohol
kills the Cola.
I mean when you're drinking jack and
cokes and you're eating ass,
the alcohol is killing any bad bacteria.
That alcohol is flushed your whole
system with poison.
Nothing's grown in that.
No,
no bacteria is going to take hold.
It's going to get swallowed up in that
whole antiseptic chemical reaction that
the Jack and coke has.
That's why you really think you can eat
ass when you're a jack and coke when
you're high.
You don't want to eat ass because when
you're high like this is probably not
the best.
I never even put like metal in there and
it cleans the metal.
Did you know that if you take jewelry
and putting on a candidate coke,
it just dissolves all the face of
coconut frog?
Yeah.
If you take a put a frog in big thing of
coke,
like a dead frog.
It just eats all the skin away and just
bone makes it go.
Is that true folks or is that one of
those?
Those do exchangers we used because I
heard that the,
the taking the paint off cars was
bullshit.
It's like bullshit.
I don't think snopes anyone do.
If you,
you know,
one of the best things to clean your
grill is coke.
Really?
Yeah.
Damn a rag.
But you know what?
The doctors,
when you haven't like a fucking barbecue
sandwich,
a nice goddamn cold cold.
It's pretty fucking delicious,
right?
So barbecue pork pulled pork sandwich.
Alright Ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
I think that's going to be the end.
We got to take one more question.
So we end on a high note.
But,
uh,
we are enjoying the fuck out of this.
Here's this.
To disclose your product has 400
witnesses proving ete life exists.
Even astronauts.
Listen,
just because you have 400 people saying
that they've seen Ufo,
that does not mean there's cfos.
That means you have 400 people that say
they've seen you have false and they
might really believe they cfos,
but you know,
they have a real problem that hunters
have a real problem.
And this exhibit,
this happens all over the world where
I'm the most experienced hunters are the
ones that wind up accidentally killing
people.
And the reason being is that these guys
are winning your experience.
Hunter,
you know that sometimes your window of
opportunity where you get a shot at a
deer is real short.
You've got to be able to react.
But the deer's right there,
you got to be able to shoot and people
see things that aren't there and one of
the things they all say a universally
when they have an accident,
and these are like good people,
church going people,
no anger,
no violence issues.
Guys are just loving on thing.
They say,
they swear they saw a deer.
They swear they saw deer.
One guy accidentally shot this,
um,
this woman,
uh,
in Maine and she had white mittens on
and he is following a deer.
And this lady was in the woods and she
had her white mittens on and he saw that
white.
And he said he saw the book.
He said he saw it.
He said it was right there in front of
him.
And he said he squeezed off the trigger.
We don't fully understand how the,
our consciousness and our imagination
affects what we see.
It's,
it's still very much.
there's something tricky to it.
Hallucinations and the ability to see
things that aren't there,
that's real.
And if someone's in a very heightened
state,
if they're in a very heightened state,
like if they're in the heightened state
of,
you know,
um,
wanting to see a deer,
or if they're in a heightened state of
being in the woods in the dark,
and you think you see a monster,
you can see a fucking monster.
You can really see it.
You can convince yourself that you've
actually seen it.
If you see something and you don't know
what it is,
you will turn it into your mind and
making a monster.
If you're out in the woods and it's
Pitch Black and you stumble into a wild
boar and you barely see it and it makes
noise and runs away,
you could,
it could be some to,
you know,
to fucking foot tall troll man with you
know,
giant fucking furry feet and glowing
eyes.
You could make something up in your head
and you don't think you're doing it,
but you're doing it.
The human imagination and human memory
or not totally to be trusted.
So unless they have actual evidence
listening to anybody talk about Ufo as
you have to listen to them and go,
hmm,
maybe,
maybe I'm not saying that you can't get,
you know,
hear from other planets.
I mean,
if you were so sophisticated that you
can travel to this world from another
galaxy or another solar system,
why wouldn't you be so sophisticated
that you could hide?
Why wouldn't you be so sophisticated
that you're,
you're Ufo is completely invisible.
Why wouldn't you be totally
undetectable?
Why wouldn't you?
I mean,
maybe they would just have everything
completely master the idea that,
you know,
they would show themselves and look like
they're dangling on a string.
Allow people to take pictures and you
know,
and they all,
maybe they wanted us to see them really.
And that's how they did it.
They just showed up and some weird
obscure place where you,
no,
come on man.
No,
that's not what they're doing.
That if,
if there really are aliens,
they're probably so alien.
You can't even recognize them.
They're probably.
I think that what we recognize is what
we see in our dimension.
What we see in our environment,
what we see in our world,
I think there's probably life forms out
there exist that are so alien to us.
We don't even have the sensors to detect
them.
You know,
and the way I've talked about this
before and I was talking about farts and
that by when someone farts,
if you don't have a nose,
you have no idea.
It stinks you.
There's literally something going around
you that's invisible and the sense that
you have tunes into it.
How do we not know that there are an
infinite amount of things that we cannot
detect that are around us all the time.
We don't.
It's just guesswork because something's
not on the same frequency as us.
Something's not solid.
It's not tangible.
You can't bang on it because just
because of that doesn't mean it's not
real and if there are aliens,
they're probably so fucking alien.
You can't even see it there.
They're probably on a totally different
frequency than we are.
I'm not buying all these dudes that say
they've seen Ufo is because they really
want to see you,
fos.
These motherfuckers want to see it.
They have all had experiences and
something's happened to them,
but they want to see you for they want
so bad they've given up on their jobs.
They've given up on their careers,
they've decided to pursue [inaudible]
full time.
They make youtube videos constantly.
They do conferences and seminars.
They have a lot of vested interests
involved in the idea of flying saucers
and ships from other planets coming to
this earth,
and there's a lot of psychological
things you have to take into
consideration like why these people want
to see these things and when these
experiences happen,
that's another thing.
People individually experiences,
especially alien abduction experiences.
Most of those things come in the middle
of the night while people are dreaming
and when you're dreaming in the middle
of the night,
your brain is producing all sorts of
psychedelic chemicals including dmt.
The most potent psychedelic known to man
is produced when you're in heavy rem
sleep.
So when these people are having these
alien abduction experiences,
how do you not know that it's not your
imagination mixed in with psychedelic
drugs that you don't even know you're
having?
You're having these things in your brain
is producing,
um,
and you're having these incredible
fucking psychedelic trips and maybe
you're halfway into a dream and you wake
up and you're tripping out of these
chemicals in your fucking brain and you
start creating all these scenarios with
your imagination.
Next thing you know,
you're on a spaceship.
Why?
Because you're in the middle of a
fucking natural dmt trip.
And if you smoked DMT,
dumb people that want money.
Joe.
Actually,
there's this,
some people that are done though.
There's some people that aren't done
that have real experiences.
You know,
I've,
I've seen their interviews,
I've read stuff they have,
I've read all the John Mac books.
So you,
some of them,
yes,
but there's a very,
it's,
there's no one you can't generalize,
but people have had ufo experiences,
but the,
any,
any supernatural,
phenomenal,
you know,
out of the ordinary experience has to be
considered in all sorts of different
ways.
Where's the evidence and what else could
it have been?
And when you look at what time these
things are taking place,
almost universally they take place late
at night when people,
especially the alien abduction
experiences almost universally take
place late at night.
And when these people have these
experiences,
they're all sleeping,
you know,
they're all like half out of it and
something happens to them.
It's much more likely an endogenous dub
of psychedelic chemicals.
Ladies and gentleman,
I'm no expert in my disclaimer.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about.
This is all shit that I've read on the
Internet and watch documentaries on and
um,
learned when I was in my isolation tech
stone.
Um,
we've had a good time here today for
either you have a good time.
Fifty percent of the time,
50 percent of the time.
What didn't you like about today?
I've heard a lot before when these
subjects come up,
a lot of times I've said,
I've talked about all the shit many
times before,
but Brian has to realize there's a lot
of people out there that have not seen
me talk about all these things before.
And when a interesting subjects like
this come up,
you know,
you gotta you gotta address it.
I think it's an important thing to talk
about.
But we had a good fucking time.
Thank you very much.
We're going to do this every week.
Like I said,
I upgraded my internet today.
Finally it's up.
So now I can get a Brian here beside us
and we can load videos up and shit.
And like I said,
behind us,
we're going to put up a green screen and
when we put up the green screen we're
going to be able to,
uh,
have like a space background and shit.
And I got all kinds of cool things
coming on.
And we're going to do this every week.
Fuck it.
It's fun.
I enjoy it.
Next week I'm going to try to bring on
my boy Joey Diaz.
Maybe Eddie Bravo would join us as well.
Maybe I should.
Fear will join us.
We might not have a whole Party in here
because next week I'm going to have a
big couch in here.
Um,
so,
uh,
thank you very much.
I had a good time.
You motherfuckers,
um,
if you,
uh,
want to come see me do stand up if
you're in Miami.
I'm at the Lincoln Theater in Miami on
the 22nd,
which is,
I think it's next Saturday or next
Friday.
Next Friday.
The,
so a nine days for today.
So thank you very much.
Everybody wants to play that thing on
fullscreen and that's how we'll end.
Thank you very much.
Love you bitches.
See you next week.